people often learn about data structures
out of context
but in this course you will learn
foundational concepts by building a real
world api
with python and flask giorgio is the
instructor
and he has a knack for helping people
understand data structures in a
practical way
hey what's up everybody my name is
giorgio and in this video we're going to
learn about what i consider to be the
most foundational data structure
concepts by building an api using flask
and python
this video is directed towards both
beginners and experienced programmers
the only prerequisite for this tutorial
is a basic understanding of python
we'll start with installing python in
flask and setting up our virtual
environment
and then we'll move into configuring our
database and
coding up our api skeleton from there
we'll add the routes to our api by
making use of data structures such as
linked lists hash tables binary search
trees and stacks and queues
and of course if you're interested in
more from me be sure to subscribe to my
youtube channel
essie like a pro for more content like
this and without further ado
let's get started to begin we'll need to
install both python and flask
the installation process for python
starts at python's website here
which i will also link in the
description so to start
you'll just want to go to this downloads
tab and then download python 3 for your
operating system
after the download is complete you'll be
able to access the installer which is
self-explanatory
once you've completed the python 3
installation process you should be able
to check that the installation was
successful by typing in
python 3
dash dash version at the command line
most likely my python version will be
different from yours i have an older
version but as long as you have the most
updated version you'll be okay for this
series
now that we have python installed we can
move on to installing flask
the flask installation documentation can
be found here
which i will also link in the
description the flask installation is
pretty straightforward
the documentation will go over the
benefits of using a virtual environment
and will also instruct us on how to set
up our virtual environment now a virtual
environment
essentially just compartmentalizes our
project and its dependencies so that
there won't be any clashes with
additional projects that we might make
in the future so within this virtual
environment that we create
all of the libraries and the version of
python that we use at the time of the
initiation of the virtual environment
will be
preserved and contained within that
environment and if in the future
you set up another python project you
would then initiate another virtual
environment for that project
specifically so to create a virtual
environment we'll first need to create a
directory that will contain our project
and then we'll cd into that directory
and we'll use this python command
to call the virtual environment module
and this here will be the directory that
the environment will be allocated to
so i'm just going to call our project
directory flask api
and then change directory into that
folder
so once we're in our project folder we
can create our virtual environment by
running the command from the flask
documentation
and once this command has completed its
execution you'll be able to see the
environment folder
by typing ls to list the contents
of your current directory and if you
change directory into this environment
bolder
and ls again you'll see the contents
contain
more subfolders but you don't actually
need to worry about what all of these
are
currently just know that whenever we
install a new library
it's going to be contained within this
folder and also our current version of
python that we use to initialize this
environment will be also contained
within this folder and we can double
check that if we ls this bin folder
and within this folder we can see our
python binaries as well as our pip
binaries
and pip is just going to be used to
install additional libraries
so we can see the back one directory
and now we're back in our project
directory so now that we've installed
our virtual environment we now need to
activate our virtual environment because
currently although we've installed the
environment we haven't yet activated it
so to activate it as we see in the
documentation here we can use this
command to activate our virtual
environment so we can just
paste that command in here and now our
virtual environment should be activated
and for most of you you'll be able to
see that the environment is activated
because you'll see
in parentheses here it'll say
environment but for me my shell is
configured in a way that doesn't allow
the display of the environment but you
can know for sure that your environment
is activated if you type in this command
so you'll type in environment and then
you'll pipe it into grep
and then you're going to grab virtual
environment
and if you type in this command you
should see an environment variable
called virtual environment that contains
the path to your virtual environment
and again the path is going to be this
venv folder that's within our project
directory
so now that we've activated our virtual
environment we can move on with
installing flask
so to install flask we just need to use
pip and run this command
pip install flask so we can just copy
and paste that and then with our
virtual environment running we can just
run pip install flask
and if you get this warning down here
that says that your version of pip
needs to be upgraded you can go ahead
and run this command
here
so once we've installed flask and we've
updated pip if necessary we can kind of
get an idea of how this virtual
environment is working
if we ls our virtual environment folder
once again
and then ls this bin folder which
contains the binaries
that we can use within this virtual
environment
and now you'll see that within this bin
folder we'll have a flask binary
so now whenever we're running this this
flask command within our virtual
environment it's going to be using
this flask binary to run the command as
opposed to any global installation of
flask that you might have on your system
so everything that we install for this
project is going to be contained within
this
environment within this environment
folder it should be noted that in a real
production application the structure of
your code will likely be different
depending on the size of the application
for the purposes of this tutorial and to
reduce the level of complexity of the
application structure in order to focus
on learning the targeted concepts
we'll write the entirety of our api with
the exception of our data structures in
one dot pi file
if you would like to later extend this
api you can easily reorganize the
structure of the application by
splitting the single dot pi
files and moving the resulting parts
around according to your needs
so we'll create our main file for our
api and we'll call it server.pi
and just a quick note throughout this
tutorial i'll be using vim as my text
editor but feel free to use whatever
ide or text editor that you feel
comfortable with it's only important
that you create a server.pi
file in our project directory to start
we'll want to import flask request in
jsonify
and we'll want to create an app variable
that points to a flask instance
and if we take a look at what this flask
object is actually doing
we'll see that this flask object
implements a whiskey application and
acts as the central object
it is passed the name of the module or
package of the application once it is
created it will act as a central
registry for the view functions the url
rules template configuration and much
more
you don't really need to know what's
happening behind the scenes here just
know that
this whiskey application is a middleware
that sits between
our python application in the server and
it's what's going to make the
implementation of our api possible
so we can go ahead and add comment here
that just says app
next we'll want to set up the database
configuration to our application
so we can add configurations to this app
that we just created
by adding them to this configuration
dictionary that's already a part of our
app
instance so if we go to the definition
here we can just see that the
configuration dictionary
behaves exactly like a regular
dictionary which means that
if we wanted to add a key for our
database
we could do it like we would add a value
to any other dictionary
and for the sake of simplicity for this
project we'll just be using an sqlite
database
which will essentially just be a local
file that will contain the data for our
database
and we can just name this file sqlite
db.file and we'll also want to create
another configuration
which we will just assign the value 0.
and we don't need to bother ourselves
with what this configuration is for
just know that if we don't add this
configuration we'll get errors
and that's about all of the
configuration that we're going to need
to use a local file as our database
we'll also need to make some additional
imports
now that we have our local database file
configured we'll need a way to access
and query that database within our
python application
and we'll do that by using this flask
sql alchemy extension
now if we access this link and go to the
home page
you can see that sql alchemy is an
object relational mapper
that gives application developers the
full power and flexibility of sql
essentially what an object relational
mapper or an orm does
is it allows you to interact with an sql
database in an object-oriented
way behind the scenes it's converting
your object-oriented code into
sql statements and queries so flask sql
alchemy
just makes sql alchemy more compatible
with flask applications
and the way this essentially is going to
work is we're going to create classes
that represent the tables in our
database so for example if we have a
table
for users with an orm we're going to
create models for each table and a user
table in class form would look something
like this
and each of these are going to be
columns within this user table
and for each column we'll have the data
type for the value and in the case of
strings we'll have the maximum number of
characters
and this last one here posts is going to
be a relationship to another table that
we're going to create called blog
posts because this api is going to be an
api for a blog website so now that we
understand what an object relational
mapper is and we understand what
sql alchemy is we can move back up to
our necessary imports and configuring
sql alchemy to work with our api
so we're going to need to import
sql alchemy
and i'll go over what these imports are
going to be used for in a second
and we're going to need to add one more
configuration because
by default sqlite doesn't enforce
foreign key constraints
so we're going to need to add an
additional section here
to configure sqlite3
to enforce foreign key
constraints
and you don't need to worry yourself too
much about what this code means
it's essentially just allowing us to
configure the db connection
to enforce foreign key constraints via
this line here
and from here we can create an instance
of our database
by passing our app into this
sql alchemy class and if we go to the
definition of this class we'll see that
this class is used to control the sql
alchemy integration to one or more flask
applications
so it's just connecting our orm with our
flask application and we'll also just
define a now variable
for date values when updating tables in
the future
so now that we've got our configuration
set up we can go ahead and save this
file
and we're going to need to install some
of the imports that we added to our
server.pi file
so first let's check to see if our
virtual environment is running by
running this command
and if you see that this virtual
environment environment variable
has the path to our projects v e and v
folder then we are good to go
so for those of you that are using mac
sqlite is already going to be
pre-installed on your system
but if you're using something like linux
then depending on your disk drill you
can install sqlite by running
apt-get install sqlite3 or
uninstall sqlite3 but again you're going
to have to
look into installing sqlite for your
particular system so we can go ahead and
do python server.buy
and we'll get errors so here it says
that no module named sql alchemy
of course because we didn't install it
yet so on really quick
let me just clarify something really
quick so if we go back into our
server.pi file
you'll see that we're importing from sql
alchemy
and we're also importing from flask sql
alchemy
so the only reason we're importing from
sql alchemy
as opposed to flask sql alchemy here
is because we need to configure sqlite
to enforce foreign key constraints
and we need to use this event and this
engine from sql alchemy to actually
make this configuration work but other
than for
this code here to enforce foreign key
constraints throughout this application
we'll be using flask sql alchemy
so to install sql alchemy we can just
run pip install
sql alchemy and if we
attempt to run our server again
we no longer get the error for no module
named sql alchemy but now we get the
error for
no module named flask sql alchemy in
which case we'll do
the exact same thing pip install
flask sql alchemy
now if we do the same thing and for some
reason
we're getting the error that i was
telling you about when we added that
additional configuration to our
application
so we set this sql alchemy track
modifications to
zero for false and it's telling us to
explicitly set it to true or false to
suppress this warning which i thought we
did but let's go ahead and have a look
and let's go ahead and see
what it's saying see if we have the
right
name for the configuration variable
and that's what i did wrong i had
sql track modifications instead of sql
alchemy track modification
so we'll go ahead and save that we'll
exit this
and let's try this again and
there we go all of our dependencies have
been successfully installed
so let's go back into our server.pi
file and from here we can move on to
creating
our additional database model so this
api
is going to be a blog api so
the two database models that we're going
to need is this
user model that we have here so we're
going to create a user table
and we're going to create a blog post
model which is going to be
a table for blog posts and we'll do that
by
doing class blog post
and it's going to take in db.model
and this db.model is coming from if we
go to the definition of db
we see that dv is an instance of this
sql alchemy class
so whenever we create a class for a
table we need to take in this db model
and we'll continue with adding a table
name
for this class and we're going to call
the table
blog post
and this table is going to have an id
column
which is going to contain integer values
and this is going to be
a primary key
and then we're going to have a title for
the blog post
and this is going to be a string with a
maximum of 50 characters
and finally we'll have the body and the
body
can be a maximum of 200 characters the
body of the blog post
and we'll take a date which is going
to be db.date and last but not least
we'll have a user id
column which will tell us which user
this blog post belongs to
it's going to be
an integer and it's going to be a
foreign key
from the user table id column
and it's not going to be nullable
so here you see that this user id in our
blog post table
is is going to have to be an id from our
user table
and it's not going to be able to be null
and this is the reason that we have to
enforce uh foreign key constraints here
because if we wouldn't have implemented
this portion
of the configuration sqlite would just
allow us
to add blog posts that don't contain
valid users
but now that we enforce foreign key
constraints the user ids that are passed
to our blog post
are going to have to be user ids that
exist within this user table
so now that we've added the classes for
our database schema
let's go ahead and generate and have a
look at what our database looks like
instead of using the command line tool
for sqlite3 to view our schema and
tables
let's download a dv browser for sqlite
which will allow us to view
our database via a graphical user
interface the db browser that we'll use
can be found here
at sqlitebrowser.org i'll add a link to
the description of this video
and once you've accessed this link
depending on your operating system
you'll download this db browser using
one of the links listed below
so in my case i'm using mac os so i
would use this link here
and once we've downloaded our db browser
we can actually
generate our database we can do this by
running the python shell from the
command line
and creating our database tables based
on the models that we've created
so we can go ahead and save this file
and exit and let's clear this
and to run the python shell all we have
to do is type in
python and to generate our database we
want to
import the sql alchemy instance which we
assigned to the variable database
and here server is just the name of our
dot pi file which is the name of our
module and then
db is the variable that we assigned to
the instance of the sql alchemy database
so once we have that imported we can now
access the methods of this db instance
and we can just type in db.create
all which will create our database by
creating the
tables based on the classes that we've
created in our server file
and then we can exit the python shell
and if we ls
we'll see that our sqlite database file
has been created and if we go back into
our server.pi
file we'll see that in our app
configuration
for sql alchemy database uri we set the
uri
to the file sqlitedb.file
which is the file that was created when
we generated the database
so our entire db is going to be
contained within this file
if we delete this file we're also
deleting our database
and we can view our database by opening
this file using the db browser that we
just created
so you can start by executing the db
browser that we installed for sqlite
and once we've opened the db browser the
interface will look like this
and we can just click this open database
and from there we can make our way to
our project directory
flask api and we'll see our sqlitedb
file here and we can just select it and
click open
and now you'll be able to see both of
our tables
and if we expand this we'll see all of
the columns for
our table and if we browse the table
we can expand these
and this is what our table for our blog
post looks like
which contains an id column a title
column a body column
a date column and a user id column
and as we can see if we go back into our
server.pi
file and we go down to our blog post
table
we can see that this corresponds exactly
with the class that we created
so we have an id column we have a title
column
we have a body column and we have a date
column and a user id column and this is
what i meant when i said that an
object relational mapper allows you to
interact with the database
in an object-oriented way we're creating
a class
that's representative of a table in an
actual sql database
so now that we've gotten everything set
up for our database we can start
creating the routes
for the api
so we can just say routes so the way
that flask works is
in order to create a function that
corresponds to a route
we need to use this app.route decorator
and within this decorator we need to
pass the rule
and the methods
and this first one will be a post and in
this route we're going to define a
function to create
a new user and for now
we'll just pass because we're just
setting up the skeleton for the
application
so if we go to the definition of route
we see that
route is a decorator that is used to
register a view function for a given url
rule
so basically what that means is the url
rule
in this case is going to be this forward
slash user
so whenever this forward slash user is
appended to our
url the request is going to be routed to
this particular function for create user
if it is a post request so what we're
going to do is we're going to
create a couple of these routes
and they're all going to serve their own
individual purpose
and we're going to create the route
function for each of these individual
routes
in future videos so for now let's just
create the skeleton of the api so this
rule
is going to be sending id
and right now you don't need to bother
yourself too much with what each of
these
individual routes and their functions
are going to do
because we're going to get to them in
future videos for now we're just
creating the skeleton of the application
and this one's going to use the kit
method
and the function's going to be called
get
all users descending
and again for now we're going to pass
and we can do the same thing
and change this to ascending
id and it will also be a get method
and we'll change this to sending
and again right now don't bother
yourself with
what each individual route is going to
be used for right now
so this here where we're adding in this
user id this is just going to
allow us to pass a user id to our path
and then we'll then be able to use this
user id variable
within this function
because we'll be able to pass it in here
so we'll be taking
this user id and passing it into this
function
get one user and the user id is just
going to be
whatever id we append to this url
and let's continue
this one will be a delete
and we'll change this to delete user
and here we're going to
create a blog post for a specific user
id
so we're still going to pass user id to
the function
and we'll change the name of this
function to create
blog post
this will be a git and we'll change this
to
user and this will be get
all blog posts
finally this will be a delete
delete blog post
and that'll be it for our routes and
lastly if
name equals
main
app.run and we want to set
debug equal to true and all this is
saying is
if we're running this server.pi file as
our main application
then we're going to start our api with
debug equal to true
and what do i mean by if we're running
this server.pi file as our main
application
all i mean is if we're running it as our
main application
on the command line we would type python
and then server.pi
so we're running this server.pi
file as our main application then this
internal
variable is going to be set to equal
main because that means that this is our
main application
because we're running this file directly
as our main application
when we pass it to this python command
so now let's save this
and let's go ahead and run this and see
if we get any errors
and as you can see our server is now
running
and debug mode is set to on and our
server is running on local host port
5000.
before we get into linked lists let's
start by adding the functionality to our
create user route
so we can start by removing this pass
and this first route is going to be
relatively simple
but it's going to tell us most of what
we need to know about how
we'll interact with the orm or the
object relational mapper which we
discussed in the previous video
so we can start by creating a variable
to store our request data
and although it might seem like this
request object is coming out of nowhere
it's actually
provided by flask and we don't really
need to know much about the underlying
implementation
just know that when we're working with
our routes we'll have available to us
this request object
and what this git json method is going
to do is
it's just going to parse our request
payload as json
allowing us to access the parameters via
their key values
for example if the request contains a
payload that looks like this
we'll be able to access this bill value
the same way that we would access a
dictionary value based on its key
so in our case this payload is going to
be data
so we'd be able to access it by doing
data
name
which is exactly what we're going to do
so we're also going to create
a new user variable and it's going to be
an instance of our user class that we
created above
here
so whenever we create a new user we're
going to have to
do it by creating an instance of the
class user so in our case
the user has a name which is just going
to be data
name and an email address and a phone
number
so
just copy these
address
and with this instance of our user class
adding this
new user to our database is as simple as
doing
dv.session dot add and then the name
of the instance followed by
db.session.commit
and this is all we'll need to do to
create a new user and once
all of this is completed successfully we
can just return
a response and we'll just do
jsonify
user created
as well as 200 and this 200 is just
going to be
the status code for our response and the
200 status just means that the request
was successful
so we can save this and we can run our
server again and see if we get any
errors
and we do not now the server is running
and now we can actually test the route
and see if it works
and to do that we're going to install an
app called postman to send requests to
our server
so to install postman what you want to
do is go to postman.com
forward slash downloads and i will put a
link in the description of this video
and you're simply going to want to click
this download the app
if you want you can use the browser
version but i recommend using
the actual application version and to
download it
it's pretty straightforward you're just
going to click this
and you're going to save this file and
you'll simply unzip this file and you'll
have the application available to you
then
and if you're using a mac you might want
to move the application that's extracted
from this zip file to the application
folder
once you have postman you can go ahead
and run the application
and once you have postman open you can
just go here and click
new and then you can create a new
collection and you can just name this
collection
flask api or whatever you like you don't
really need to do a description
i'll just hit create and after you've
created your collection you should see
it here
and then you can just expand this and
hit add request
and here we'll just name the request
create user and again we don't need to
do a description and we can just
save to flask api collection and then
you'll have a request within this
collection called create user and you
can just click that
and you'll be presented with a tab that
says create user that looks something
like this
and here it says enter request url and
then now it says that we're running our
server on
localhost port 5000 which is our request
url so we can just copy this
and then paste it into this request url
section
and for this create user request we're
going to be
calling our create user route let me
just open
another tab here and let's just change
directory to
flask api and we can just go back into
our server.buy again
and let's go down so the route that
we're working with
is this route here and as you can see
our rule is forward slash user so we're
going to need to append this forward
slash user to
our url and it's going to be a post
request
so back in postman we can just put user
here
so now we have our forward slash user
rule
and we can change this get method to
post and then what we need to do is we
need to go down to this body tab
and we're going to use raw and we're
going to change this from text
to json and now we can input our
request payload it's going to be named
bill it doesn't really matter email
test email.com
address just a random address
281 street and just a random number
for the zip code and then lastly
phone and let's just put some random
numbers in there
so this is going to be our payload and
our
server is running in this tab we can see
that our server is still running
so now we can go ahead and try and send
our request by hitting this send button
here
and once we send the request we can see
the results
some of you guys might have this result
section hidden so we can just expand
this down here
to see the results and as you can see we
have a status
200 which is a success response which is
okay
and it even says here standard response
for successful http requests
which is helpful and we also have our
message here that we return after we've
successfully created a new user which is
just message user created
in json format so since we were able to
successfully create this new user
we should be able to see the record for
this new user in our database
so let's go ahead and open up the db
browser that we downloaded and make sure
everything is working as expected so
let's just start the db browser
application
and once we've started the application
we can just go up here
and select open database
and from here we'll want to traverse to
the path of our database file which is
flask api which is our application
directory
and within our application directory you
should have this
sqlitedb.file which is our database file
this file contains the entirety of our
database
and we can just select this and click
open and from here we can go to our user
table and we can right click it
and then just select browse table and
you should see a row for the user that
we just sent to request to create
so this means that everything is working
as expected with our user route
so now that we've set up postman and
we've created this initial route to
create
users we can go ahead and move on to the
next route
which is this route to get all
users in descending order and this route
is where we're going to make use of
linked lists so we're going to come back
to the code for this function here
after we write the code for our linked
list so let's go ahead and save this
file and quit and if we ls here
we'll see that we have our server.pi
file in our database file here
as well as our virtual environment and
you don't really have to worry about
this pi
cache and throughout this series for our
data structures to separate concerns
we're going to create the data
structures in separate files
so we can just create another file in
our directory and we can call it linked
lists dot pi and again you don't have to
use vim to create the file you can
create the file
in any way that you choose just make
sure that it's in our project directory
the same directory as our server.pi file
now when we cut up these data structures
i'm going to both
write out the code for the data
structures as well as try to explain how
you can visualize the data structures by
using blackboard so
i'm going to switch between two
different methods of teaching to kind of
attempt to give you guys a better
understanding of what's happening here
so if you don't understand what
something is after i write out the code
for it just try to stick with me
i will go into more detail throughout
these portions of the tutorial
so to start we're going to create a
class called node which will initialize
with three parameters self
data and next node
and we'll set data in next node's
defaults to none
and self.data will equal data which will
either default to none or equal the
argument passed for data at the time of
instantiation and the same
for next node it's going to equal next
node which again will either be none
or the argument passed for next node at
the time of instantiation
so what do i mean by at the time of
instantiation so if we were to create a
new instance of node like so
we'll just call it node one which is a
new instance of node
this is us instantiating the node class
so in other words we're setting this
node 1 variable equal to a new instance
of node so this node 1 variable will be
bound to a node object
in memory and if we instantiate this
node without passing any arguments to it
we're going to default both data and
next node to none but if we were to pass
in
arguments for data and next node let's
say for example we have another node and
we can just call this one node two
and we wanted this node to be the next
node from node one
we could instantiate this first node
with some data and for our next node we
could use the argument node2
and in this case both our next node and
our data will no longer default to none
self.data will be set equal to the data
that we passed
and the same for self.nextnode it will
be set to the next note that we
passed at the time of instantiation
which brings us to the meaning of self
here
if you're new to python self just
represents a specific
instance of a class so whenever we
instantiate this node class we're
essentially making a copy of a node
object in memory so that means when we
set this node one
equal to an instance of the node class
we're creating one node object in memory
which can be referenced by using
this node one variable and then we set
this node two variable equal to an
instance of the node class we're
creating another copy of a node object
in memory which can be referenced by
using this node2 variable
so at this point we have two copies of
the node object in memory
each which can be accessed by using
their corresponding variable names node
1 and node 2.
so when we initialize with this self
parameter it's basically representative
of
a particular instance of this node class
so when we set self.data equal to data
it's setting the data value for
that copy or object in memory equal to
the data that we pass when instantiating
and also actually we wouldn't be able to
reference this node 2 here
without first instantiating it so let's
move this here
so now we create an instance called node
2 and then we create an instance called
node 1
which has a next node that is equal to
node 2.
so after we create our node class we'll
create a wrapper class which we'll just
call linked list
which will initialize with self only
and for this class we'll have a head
which we'll set equal to none
and we'll have last node we'll set equal
to none as well
so let's try to visualize what's
happening here so if we visualize a
linked list it looks something like this
and each of these rectangles within this
linked list
are nodes within the length list and
each node has two separate compartments
we have this left compartment here which
contains the data
and which in this case is going to be a
string a
and then we have this compartment here
which contains the pointer that points
to the next node
and if you look at our linked list class
you see that we also have this
data compartment here and we have this
next
node pointer here as well but it should
be noted that in python
variables are just names bound to
objects so this next node variable isn't
actually a pointer
when this next node variable is
initialized it will be bound to the
object
that it's set equal to so when we create
a new instance of node
and we pass a next node to it this
next node variable is going to be bound
to the next node that we passed to it
but for our purposes it's okay to think
of this next node as a pointer because
it will actually help you visualize
things better when you think of this
next node as a pointer
for example let's say that we create an
instance of our node class and we'll
just call it node 1
and we'll set it equal to a new instance
of node
and we'll pass a string that just
contains the word data as our data
and we'll pass none as our next node
so what this is going to look like is
we'll have
node 1 which is this rectangle
and we'll have this compartment that
contains the string data
as our data and then we'll have this
compartment which contains our pointer
to none
and if we were to go ahead and create
another
instance of node and we'll just call
this one node two
and it would just be an instance of our
node class
and we would pass data to this one as
well but this time
as our next node we would pass in node
1 which would look like this we would
get
another rectangle here and then this one
will also just contain a string that
says data
but then this one's pointer is going to
be pointing to
our node one and we can continue to do
this to build
a linked list that can look something
like this but what is this length list
wrapper actually for well this linked
list wrapper is actually going to help
us keep track of the head of our linked
list
so if you look at this length list image
here you see that
this first note of the linked list is
the head
so the first node within a linked list
is going to be the head of the linked
list
and here if we were to just continue to
instantiate
node objects just randomly throughout an
application it'd be quite difficult for
us to keep track of
which one of these nodes that we
instantiate is the head
because the only way to check which one
of these instances is the head of the
linked list is to actually go through
each instantiation and then check
which nodes are being passed as next
node eventually
after lots of unnecessary stress we can
kind of figure out what the head of the
linked list is but we can solve this
problem by just
creating this linked list wrapper which
keeps track of the head of our linked
list
so whenever we want to add to our linked
list we can either add to the beginning
of the linked list or the end of the
linked list
and within this linked list class we
would create a method for both adding to
the end of the linked list
and the head of the linked list so for
example
if we were to define a method here
called insert
beginning
and it took in self
and data we'd basically be able to do
something similar to
saying node is equal to a new instance
of node
then we pass in the data
and then we can say our next node is
whatever
our current head is so self
dot head
and what that would do is say for
example this is
our current head and we want to add a
note to the beginning here
this node is going to contain
data and it's pointing to
our current head so in that case this
node would no longer be
our head this node would now be our head
because we set this node's next node
to self.head which is the current head
which is this one but once we've done
this
we need to make sure that we keep our
head variable updated
so we would then set self.head equal to
this node so we'll go self
dot head equals
node and this is just pseudo code we're
actually going to write this out within
the application but this is just so you
guys can get a grasp of what's happening
here when we add to the beginning
of the linked list and adding to the end
would actually be a different story
because we're going to have to
keep checking the next node next node
next node until we reach a node whose
next node is null or
none and we'll get to that in a little
bit it's one of the reasons why we're
going to be keeping track of the last
node as well
but for now it's only important that you
understand how this node is working
as well as why we're wrapping it in this
linked list class
okay so now that we have a general
understanding of how our
node and linked list classes work let's
create a print method within our linked
list class so that we can keep track of
what's going on
so we can just add a new method
we can just call it print linked list
and we'll start by just initializing a
variable
to hold the string that will print at
the end of the function which we'll call
ll string which we'll set equal to an
empty string
so we'll start by setting node equal to
self.head which is going to be the head
of our linked list
and if node is none that means that this
linked list is empty
because the head of the linked list is
none so if that's the case we're just
going to print none
otherwise we'll use a while loop to
traverse the linked list so we'll just
do while node
which just means that while node is not
equal to none we're going to
append to our string ll string
plus equals and we'll use an f string
because we need to add in
node.data and we'll cast this to a
string
just in case the data isn't already a
string and to help us visualize we'll
add a visual representation of a pointer
and here if our next node
is none then we'll just append that next
note to the
string because the while loop will never
get to a note that's equal to none
and once this is finished we move on to
the next node so we'll set note equal to
node.nextnode and after this while loop
is complete then we'll just print
ll string so let's take a couple of
seconds to go over what's happening here
so
while node isn't equal to none we're
going to perform
this code and what this code is doing is
it's just going to append the data for
each node
to this string that we're going to print
after the while loop is complete
and the string is going to look like a
visual representation of a linked list
actually to make things less complicated
we can just remove this and we can take
this
and we can just put it before the print
statement after the while loop
and if we do that then once we've
appended all the nodes with data to our
string
we'll always append none to the end of
the string
because there's always going to be an
empty node at the end of the linked list
and then we'll just go ahead and print
our string so let's see if this is
working as expected
we'll just create an instance of linked
list
and then we'll just create some nodes
and let's see
have one more so this node one here is
going to be the head of our linked list
so we need to
change this to node to point to node two
and we need to change this one to point
to node three
and this one we need to change it to
point to node four
and this node four is going to be the
last node of our linked list so its next
node is going to be none
and then once we've done that we can set
our linked list head
equal to node one and then we can just
do
ll print ll
and let's see what happens type in
python linked list dot pi
and we get our linked lists it looks
kind of strange because the data is the
same for every single node
so let's go in here and let's just add
in
their corresponding numbers
so now you see that we have data 1 data
2 data 3 data 4 and then none
so this is our visual representation of
the linked list
that's being printed using the print
method that we just created
so now that we have a way to print our
linked lists
instead of manually creating the nodes
and connecting them
like we just did we need to add in
methods for
inserting at the beginning of the linked
list and inserting at the end of the
linked list
so first we'll start with insert
beginning
and it will take data and this word is
wrong
insert so to insert at the beginning
we're going to do something similar to
what we did
on the blackboard with the pseudocode
we're going to create
a new node and it's going to contain the
data that we passed
and its next node is going to be our
current head and then we're going to set
our new head equal to this new node so
self.head is now going to be equal to
new node so let's just go ahead and test
that out
we'll create another linked list
and we'll do ll dot insert at beginning
and then we'll put in some data then
we'll do ll.print
and then let's see what happens and we
get our linked list with data inserted
at the beginning so
let's go back in here and see if we can
add to the beginning so before
our beginning contain data then we'll
have not data
so this not data should be the new
beginning
let's do python and then yeah we have
not data and then data and then none
so we can continue to insert at the
beginning
and it's always going to push the
current beginning towards the end so
we'll just change this to
just something random
and now we have cow not data data none
so our print function and our insert at
beginning functions are working as
expected
so now we need to create a method for
insert
at the end so let's go ahead and add
that
and insert at end
so when inserting at the end we just
want to make sure the linked list is not
empty first
and actually if the linked list is empty
we'll just call the
insert at beginning function to make
things simple so to check to see if the
linked list is empty we'll just do if
self.head
is none if it is we'll just do self dot
insert at beginning and we'll pass to it
data which we
need to add here as well sorry about
that now that that's out of the way
so to add to the end of a linked list
it's actually going to take
oven time because we're going to need to
traverse through each node
and check if the next node is equal to
none and that's how we'll know that
we've reached the end of our linked list
but for our class in particular
we're going to keep track of the last
node so that we can reduce the time that
it takes to insert a node at the end
in the future but if we haven't yet
started keeping track of the last node
then we're still going to have to use a
while loop to traverse through the
linked list
so we'll do if self.lastnode is none
then we'll do our while loop so we'll do
node is equal to self.head
and we just need to do while
node.nextnode
node equals node.nextnode
and this is going to take us all the way
to the end until
node.nextnode is equal to none because
we're only going to go through this
while loop while node.nextnode is not
equal to none
and for each iteration of this while
loop we're going to set node equal to
next node so once we get to the last
node of this linked list this while loop
is going to terminate
and then node is going to be set equal
to the last node of the linked list so
now we want to set the next node of our
current last node to
the data so node.nextnode
equals node and then our data
and then none because this is going to
be our new last node so the next node of
this node is going to be none
and now that we know what our last node
is we can set self.lastnode
equal to the node that we just created
which is node.nextnote so now we have a
last node so now if we wanted to
insert at the end of this instance of
our linked list
it's going to first check to see if
self.lastnote is none
but for this instance self.lastnode is
set to
our currentlastnode so now we can add
the code for if we do have self.lastnode
set
so if we do have self.lastnode we just
need to set self.lastnode.nextnode
equal to a new node
and we no longer have to take oven time
to traverse through the linked list
to get to the end and insert at the end
and we can't forget to set our
new last node as well which is again
going to be the node that we just
created which is self.lastnode.nextnode
so with the current way that we're doing
things we're only ever going to need to
iterate through this while loop the
first time we call this
insert at end method so for example
let's say
we go down here and we create a linked
list
and we do ll insert at beginning
and we just insert some data
and we do this a couple of times
and then we do ll insert at end
and then we'll say end when we get to
this insert at
end we're going to have to iterate
through all of these
inserts that we did and we can see what
this looks like
by just going to this while loop and
printing say editor
node.data then we can just save this
and then we can go python linkedlist.pi
and you'll see that when we get to the
call to insert at end it has to
iterate through every node that we
called that
insert at beginning function on but if
we go back in here
and we add another insert at end for
this next one we're not going to have to
iterate through those anymore because
after calling insert at in this first
time we started keeping track of the end
of our linked list
so you'll see when we call this again
it's still only going to iterate through
all of these nodes the one
time and if we go ahead and print the
linked list
we can see that we are indeed having our
end
and our n2 added to the end so with that
in mind
this actually means that we can make the
efficiency of
our linked list even better because to
avoid traversing this while loop all we
have to do is
keep track of our end whenever we insert
into the length list
and currently we keep track of the end
when we insert at the end
but we can also keep track of the end
when we insert at the beginning
because the first time we insert into
the linked list our linked list will be
empty and when we
insert one node into an empty linked
list at that moment
the end and the beginning of the linked
list is the same because
there's only one node in the linked list
so at that moment
we have a linked list that looks like
this and when we insert data at the
beginning we end up with a linked list
that looks like this
and when we have a linked list that
looks like this the end of our linked
list
is the head of our linked list as well
so what we can do is
we can say itself.head is
none that means our linked list is empty
and if that's the case we can just set
self.head
equal to a new node that will just
contain data and then
none for its next and we can also set
self.lastnode
equal to self.head so this means that
from the very beginning whenever we add
to our linked list we're going to start
off by keeping track of the last node of
the linked list
therefore we will actually never need to
use this
while loop so this means that we should
never get to this
if statement so if we print here last
node
is none
and we save and we run this again you'll
see that we never get to that print
statement that says last node is none
and we're not doing anything different
here we're still inserting all of this
data at the beginning
and then we're still inserting that in
for this first time and then the second
time
and before when we insert it for this
first time we have to start keeping
track of the last node when we insert
data for the first time
we automatically start keeping track of
the last node therefore we never even
have to use the while loop
so we'll actually never even get to this
code here so we can just remove it so
we'll just comment it out for now
and we can comment out this as well and
let's just do this and save
and try this again and we still have no
errors
so let's take some time to visualize
what's happening here so before adding
this code here
if we were to start with a linked list
where the head was none
so an empty linked list we would just
create a new node
with some data and we'd set
the next node of that new node to our
head
which would in turn add a linked list to
the beginning here
because this new node has its next node
pointing to our current head which is
none
and then the data would be in here and
then our head we would set it
to our new node
so this would no longer be our head our
head would now be here
so that's what we were doing before we
added this code we weren't keeping track
of last note at all we were only keeping
track of our head so in that case when
we went to insert at the end of a length
list
let's erase this
and let's say for example we did insert
beginning
a couple of times
and remember this is prior to
implementing this portion of the code so
that would leave us with a linked list
that looked something like this
with this data being here
and this data being here and if after
that we went on to insert at the end
let's say insert at end
in that case we would skip this portion
of the code because our linked list
isn't empty and we're still imagining
that we haven't implemented
this so therefore we haven't commented
out this yet as well so we would end up
here
if self.lastnode is none and since
before implementing this we weren't
keeping track of the last node it would
be none and then that's when we would
have to go through our while loop
so we would set node equal to
our head and we would just say while
our node has a next node that's not
equal to none
so while our node has a next node that's
not equal to none
we would just set our node
equal to node.nextnode
so we would start at our head which is
here
so this is our head and this is our
head's next node
and this next node isn't equal to none
so our node would then be equal
to this node and then this is our next
node and it is equal to none
so at that point this while loop would
terminate and this node value
this node value let's do a different
color
this node value is now this node and its
next node is this node
so now we set this node's next node
equal to this data that we want to
insert
so we would do node
then data and then none
so that would make this data replace
this
none so we would add a node here
and then this one would now point to
none
and that's how we were inserting that in
before and as you can see we have to
traverse through each node so we have to
go from this node to this node all the
way until the next node is none then we
can add it there
because we don't know what the last node
is and at that point that's when we are
getting our last node
and setting it equal to this node
dot next node
this node.nextnode that we just created
and at that point we started keeping
track of our last node
so now let's erase this
and let's say our linked list
is still the same length list
so at this point if we want to insert
and now we know that this is
our last node
and this is our head
so now if we want to insert
at end
all we need to do is insert at this
node's next
node so all we would have to do is last
node
dot next node
equals a new instance of node
plus our data and then none
and we no longer have to traverse
through
each node to find out what our last node
is because we already know what our last
node is
and this was all prior to us adding this
to insert at beginning and prior to us
commenting
out this while loop section but let's go
over what changed once we added this
code
and commented out this code let's erase
this again
so in this case if we insert at
beginning
just say data we'd end up at this here
and currently we just have an empty
linked list that looks like this it just
has none and this none
is our head so we end up here if
self.head is none
which it is self.head equals our new
node and our new node's next node is
just going to be none
so that just means our new node would go
here and its next node would be none
and this would no longer be our head our
head would now be our new node
and this is the data so we've updated
the head but now
as you can see in a length list that
only has one node
and its next node is none the head and
the tail are both going to be the same
node because
there's no other node after this head
node so this would be our head
and our tail so that's why we're setting
self.last node equal to self.head
because we're making the head as well as
our last node
equal to this node so now whenever we go
to this insert at end code
we can just add it straight here and
then just point this to none
this new node that we create we just
point it to none so this data
will just go right here and then we'd
set last node
equal to this new node that we just
created
so this is no longer our last node this
is now our last node
and even if we come in and insert at
beginning
we'd still just be adding a new node
here and setting its
next pointer to the current head then
this data
would be this data then this would no
longer be our head
because we're setting self.head to the
new node
so this would be our new head and at
this point we still have our head that
we're keeping track of and we still have
our last node that we're keeping track
of
which is why we'll never have to use
this code
okay so now that we understand why we no
longer need this while loop we can go
ahead and just remove this portion of
the code here and we can also get rid of
this
so now our insert at in function is a
lot cleaner and
inserting at the end will also now only
take constant time
so both our insert at beginning and
insert at in methods are of one
so we can just save this and let's just
ls our current directory
what we're going to want to do is we're
going to want to open our server.pi file
and we're going to want to import
our list.pi file and to do that we can
just do
import linked list so linked list is the
name of our file which is the name of
our module for linked lists
and now we can go down back to this
route that we're trying to implement
and what we want to do in this route is
we want to get all of our users
in descending order and to get our users
in descending order we're going to start
by querying
our database to get all of our users
and to do that we're just going to
create this users variable
and we're going to use user.query.all
and again this user here is just the
user model that we created before
so once we get all of our users we can
create an instance of a linked list
from our module and then our linked list
and then we're just going to iterate
through our users
from the database and for each user
we're going to insert at the beginning
a dictionary that contains our user data
and then we're going to need to return
this linked list and to return it we're
actually going to need to convert the
linked list into an array
so we're going to return jsonify
all users ll.2
array and we haven't yet added this to
array method to our linked list class so
let's go ahead and do that
so you guys are going to need to
traverse to your linked list file again
and we're going to add a new method
which we'll call
to array and it's going to take self
and we'll just set array equal to an
empty array and if our linked list is
empty
we're just going to return the empty
array
and if it's not empty we're going to
traverse through our linked lists
using a while loop which you all should
be familiar with because it's what we've
been doing
so we'll set node equal to self.head and
then while
node we'll do array.pinned
node.data then node equals node.nextnode
and after that while loop is finished
our array will contain
all of our node data so we can return
array
and we can save this and now when we're
back in this file
this return json file all users ll2
array should work
and i just realized we probably
shouldn't call this array because this
is python
so we'll just call it to list and here
we'll do the same thing
and we'll just call this l
l and same thing here
and also we're going to want to return a
200 here as well
the same as the way that we did it when
we created a new user we returned a 200
which is a success response and the
reason this code
is going to return all of our users with
their ids in
descending order is because this code
here this query all gives us the users
in ascending order by id and for each
user in this ascending ordered list
we're going to insert it at the
beginning of our linked list
so every time we add a user it's going
to push back
the previous user that we added so that
means that if our first user id is one
and we insert it at beginning and then
our next user id is two
and then we insert that at beginning
that one gets pushed back and it's going
to keep doing that
all the way until we get to let's say we
have
200 users so in this linked list the
user with id 200
is going to be inserted at the beginning
last so that means that
the user with id 200 is going to be the
head of our linked list
and the first user user 1 is going to be
the tail of our linked list and that's
how we're creating a list of users in
descending order by using this linked
list
i hope that makes sense and before we
move forward i noticed that there was an
error
in one of the methods of our linked list
so let's go ahead and have a look at
that
so this should be changed to l
okay so now that we have everything
situated we can
move forward with testing our route and
to do that we're going to need to
add some dummy data to our database so
what we can do is create a new file
called
generate dummy data
and i've already written the script to
generate this dummy data because i
didn't want it to detract from the
concepts that we're trying
to learn so what you can do is you can
go to this github repository
by accessing this url which i will link
in the description
and here you can just select raw and you
can just copy this code
and paste it into the file that we just
created
and then we can save this file and now
we have our file to generate dummy data
so let's have one quick look at our
database before we generate the data
so you can once again open this db
browser for sqlite
and you can select open database and
navigate to the directory of our project
and within that directory you select the
sqlitedb file
and open it and we can just browse our
table
for our blog posts and as you can see we
have no rows
and the same thing for our users we only
have this one user that we added when we
were testing
our create user endpoint and let's just
check to make sure our virtual
environment is still running by typing
in environment graph
virtual environment and as you can see
my virtual environment is still running
and yours should still be running as
well so you should have a virtual
environment environment variable that
points to the path of our project
and its venv folder and once that's done
we should be able to type in python
generate dummydata.pi and there's no
need to panic when we run this
we're going to get some errors because
there's some dependencies that we still
need to install to run this script
but we're going to run it just so we can
see what we need to install
so we'll type in python generate
dummydata.pi
and it says that there's no module named
faker so we can do pip
install baker
and then we can try this again
and this time we get no errors and if we
go and check our database now
and we check browse table for our user
table
you'll see that we have a bunch of new
users that have been added
and if we go back to database structure
and we go to our blog post and we select
browse table
we get the same thing so each blog post
has a body
and a title and it also contains
user ids that exist within our user
table
so now that we have our dummy data set
up we can finally test the route that we
created
to get users in descending order so to
do that we're going to need to run our
server
and once our server is up and running we
need to go back to
using postman to send a request so you
can select your postman app
and what we're going to want to do is
we're going to want to create a new
request
so this is our create user request so we
don't want to do anything to change this
we want to expand this flask api and
hit this view more actions and then hit
add request
and this request will be called get
users
descending and of course we don't need a
description
and it's already going to be saved to
our flask api
folder so we can just hit save to flask
api and now we can open a tab for this
request
and once again we will copy this url
here
and paste it here and we need to add our
rule here as well
so open another tab
and then we can go into our server.pi
file and the rule for this route is
going to be
forward slash user and then forward
slash descending id
so we can just copy this and paste it
here and this is going to be a git
request so we can leave this method the
same and for this request
we don't need a body so we can just hit
syn to send this request
and we got an error and it's a 500
internal server error so that means that
there's
an issue with our code somewhere so if
we go back to our server
and looking at our stack trace we can
see that at the bottom here
in our server.pi file on line 73
in the function get all users descending
we have a line that says address
is user.address and we're missing an s
here in this address
and the error is user object has no
attribute address because we spelled
address wrong
so what we can do is we can control c we
can go back into our server.pi
file and we can go to line 73
and we'll see right here that address is
spelled wrong
so we just want this to be spelled
correctly and then we can save that
and then we can run our server again
and let's try sending this request again
and this time we get a success response
a 200 status
and as you can see we have our users
in descending order by id so descending
meaning that
the users will be ordered from largest
id
to smallest id so we have id 200 here
and if we keep going down all the way
down eventually we get to the last user
which is id
1. so now that we know that that
endpoint is working we can go back into
our server.pi file
and we can start on the code for our get
all users ascending route so this route
is going to be very similar to the above
route
and since these routes are so similar we
can just go ahead
and copy this
and paste it here and the only thing
we're going to need to change is
this to insert at end and the reason
this is going to work is
if this returns all of our users in
ascending order and we iterate through
our users in ascending order and we
insert them at the end of our linked
list
we're basically just going to be
retaining the order of this
when we add it to our linked list so
actually using a linked list for this
route is redundant but the purpose of
using it is to help you understand the
differences between inserting at the end
of a linked list and inserting at the
beginning of a linked list so now we can
take our rule here
and in postman we want to create another
request
and this one's going to be get users
ascending and we'll open another tab
and this one's also going to be a get
request
and we'll go ahead and add in our rule
and let's just take our url from here
and back in our file here we can just
save this and once the file is saved
our server should already detect the
change in the file
so it will actually reload our server so
we don't have to restart our server we
can just
leave it as it is and back in postman we
can go ahead
and send this request and as you can see
we get a success response a 200 status
and we have our users here in ascending
order starting with the lowest id
and ending with the highest id
so we can go back into our file and move
on to our next route
okay so the next route that we're going
to be creating is the route to get one
user
and the way that we're going to do that
is we're going to
go ahead and create another linked list
users equals user.query.all
and we'll do all users ll equals
linkedlist. linked list
and we can just take this
paste it here and change this
to insert at beginning and we can just
go
user equals all users
ll dot get
user by id
and we'll pass in user id and we can
just
return jsonify
user with the status 200.
okay so we haven't yet created this git
user by id
so we're going to need to go back into
our linked list
file and create this method and what
we're passing to this method
is the user id which is going to come
from
our url here so we're going to have this
rule appended to our url
which is going to contain this user id
so whenever we append an id to the end
of
our url when using this rule and we use
a get request
it's going to know to route that request
to
get one user and that user id that we
append to the url is going
to be passed to our function our get one
user function
which we'll have access to within this
function which is what we're going to
pass
to this method that we are going to
implement on our linked list
so we can save this file and we can go
back into
our linked list file and within
this linked list class we can go and
create the method
we'll just define a new method here and
we're going to call it get
user by id and it's going to take in
self and user id and this method's going
to be quite simple we're just going to
use a while loop to
traverse our length list until we find
the node that contains the id
that we're looking for within its data
so we can just set a node variable equal
to self.head
and then as usual while node if
node.data
and then within that data there should
be an id
because if you remember from the route
function the data that we added to this
linked list
is a dictionary and if that's not clear
let's go back into that file
so here we're creating an instance of a
linked list
and then in this for loop here we're
going to
iterate through every user from here
and then we're going to insert the user
into our linked list by using the insert
beginning method
and the data that we're inserting is
this dictionary here and within this
dictionary we have
an id key a name key an email key an
address key and a phone key
and we're checking to see if the user id
is equal to the user id that we're
searching for
when we're using our get user by id
method so if we go back to this method
we're going to check if the node's data
which is a dictionary that contains the
key id
if that id is equal to this id that
we're passing to the method
so if that id is user id
then we're going to return node.data so
we're going to return
the dictionary that's stored as the data
in this node
and if not we're going to keep looking
so we're just going to set node equal to
node.nextnode and if
after the while loop completes we never
return
node.data it means that the user id was
never found within our linked lists
so we would just return none and then we
can just save this
and go back into our server file and go
back down
to our get one user function and as you
can see
in this get user by id method we're
going to
return the user dictionary and that's
going to be stored in this user variable
and then we're going to return the user
variable convert it to json
so let's go ahead and test this out so
to test it out once again we're going to
need to copy our rule here
and in postman we can add another
request
and we'll call this one get one user
and save then we can just go to this get
one user tab
and we can add in our rule so first
let's add in the rest of this
and this user id needs to change to the
id that we want to find
so maybe we want to get user with id15
and we have the method set to git and we
can just send
oh and i stopped my server so let's go
ahead and start the server again first
so
python server.pi the server is now
running
and then here i can hit send again and
in the response i got null so it's
saying that
the user with id 15 doesn't exist
try it with one okay so clearly there's
an issue with the code so let's go see
what's happening
so we can go to the get user by id
method
and maybe the issue is that we need to
convert this into an int
and let's save and the server should
automatically detect the change in
update and then we can
send again and now we get the user for
id one and let's try it again with 15
and we also get the user with id15 so
now we can go back into our server.pi
file so now that we can get one user we
can quickly
add the functionality here to delete a
user
and for this function we're not going to
use the linked list we're just going to
query the database to delete the user so
we can remove this path
and we can just do user equals
user.query
and now we're going to use the method
filter by
and we're going to filter by the id
equal to user
id and we want to get the first record
that we find with that id
and once we do that we can delete it by
just doing db
session dot delete and pass in the user
and then we can just do db session dot
commit
and once it's deleted we can just return
jsonify
and we'll just do an empty dictionary
and 200 and we can save and in flask api
we can just go
add request once again and this one
we'll call delete user
and save then we can just open a tab for
delete user
we can take this one and copy the whole
thing
because it's actually going to be the
same url but we're just going to change
this from git
to delete and let's say we want to
delete user one
so if we go back into our database and
we browse
table we see that we have user here with
id1
bill his name is bill and we can go
ahead and send this request to delete
oops and we got an error so let's see
and the issue here is that we're trying
to delete a user
that has blog posts in the blog post
table
and what that means is if we go check
our blog post table within our database
you can see that we have records for
blog posts that belong to the user that
we're trying
to delete user id 1 and since we've
added a foreign key constraint
to the user id column of the blog post
table
it means that values within the user id
column cannot be values that do not
actually exist within the user table
this is why we're being blocked from
deleting the user
because we need to cascade the deletion
down to the tables that reference this
user's
id when deleting which just means that
when we delete a user
any table that references that user
should have the rows that reference that
user deleted as well
and this is actually very simple we just
need to go back into our server.pi file
and here where we create the
relationship to blog post
we can just add cascade equals
all delete which just means that
whenever we delete a user
any item in this blog post table that
references that user will also be
deleted
so we can just save this and just to
recap we have
records within our blog post table that
reference user id 1
and we also have user id 1 within our
user table
so let's try sending this request to
delete user id 1 again
and now as you can see we get the
expected response
and if we go back into our database
viewer and we refresh this page
you'll see that we're now starting from
user id 2
and user id 1 bill no longer exists
within this table
and also if we go to blog post you'll
see that
the user id column no longer has
references to user id 1
because those were also deleted
so to start within our project directory
we want to create a file called
hashtable.pi
and within this file similarly to linked
lists we're going to create a node class
which will initialize with self data and
nextnode
and this time when we create an instance
of node the data that we pass to the
instance
is also going to be derived from its own
class which we'll call
data
and the data class we'll initialize with
self key and value
and lastly we will need to create a hash
table class
which will initialize with self and
table size
and within our hash table class we'll
also implement
an attribute called hash table which is
essentially
a fixed length list
and since there's no real way to declare
a fixed length list or array in python
we can use our table size variable to
create a list of none values
of the length specified by our table
size
and i'm going to explain in more detail
how all of this is working in just a
second just try to
follow along with me for now so the next
thing that we need to do
is we need to define a method within our
hash table class
which is going to generate a hash value
for us
which essentially just converts a key
into an index in our
hash table list this way we can access
the value for a key
in constant time because accessing an
index within a list takes all of one or
constant time
and again if this isn't making any sense
to you just bear with me
i will go into more detail in just a
second
so for this we're going to define a
method called custom hash
which will take in self and key and
initially our hash
value will start off as zero and for
each character
in our key
we're going to add to our hash value
the integer representation of this
unicode character
for example the character a's integer
value and unicode
would be 65 and this 65
is defined by the unicode standard so
the character a's
integer value will always equal 65. and
in python to make that conversion we can
use this
ord function and just pass in our
character
so we're adding to this hash value the
integer value for
each character in our key and the goal
is to make this hash value
as unique as possible and with only
adding
the integer values for each character
together to create our hash value
you can see how different keys can
easily add up to the same value
resulting in the same hash value for two
separate keys so we want to try to
reduce that
possibility by adding some additional
randomness to the
creation of our hash value so we can
also do hash value
equals our current hash value
multiplied by the integer representation
of our unicode character
modulo our table size
and at this point we can return our hash
value
and now that we have our custom hash
method we can add a method to
add a key value pair to our hash table
which will take in self key and value
and to add a key value pair to our hash
table first we need to create our hashed
key
by using the method that we just created
to convert our key
into a hash value and if the index of
our hashed key is none
we're going to add a new node to that
index of our hash table
by creating an instance of our node
class which takes in an instance of our
data class
as well as next node and our data class
will contain the key
and the value that we pass to our add
key value method
and we're going to get to this else soon
but first let's go over
everything that we have so far okay so
let's take some time to try and
visualize what we have so far
so we're already familiar with a way to
visualize this node here
from a previous video's explanation of
linked lists
so a node will be represented by a
rectangle
which contains the data and then the
pointer to
our next node and our data class here
is going to be what is passed to our
node so with both of these combined
we'll essentially end up with something
that looks like this
we'll have a rectangle for our node
and we'll have our pointer to next node
and for data we'll have a
key and a value so when we create an
instance of this node class we're just
creating
a node that looks like this and when we
create an instance of data
we're just creating the data within the
node which contains a key and a value
which can be seen here self.key and
self.value
now for our hash table when we create an
instance of a hash table
we're going to initialize it with the
size and the reason we're going to
need to initialize it with the size is
because when we call this custom hash
function
we want the hash that's created to stay
within the bounds of this hash table
list that we create
for example if we create a list that
only contains three items like so
this list will only have indexes zero
through two
so zero one two and if when we create
this custom hash
it exceeds the indexes of the list that
we have and we won't be able to
add the value at this hash if it doesn't
exist within our list
so say for example our custom hash
converts this key
into index 5. index 5 would be somewhere
out here which would not be within the
bounds of our list
so this would result in an error but
when we initialize our hash table with
the table
size when we calculate our hash value we
can be sure to use the module
operator to ensure that our hash value
doesn't exceed the table size
and the reason why this module operator
works to make sure that the hash value
never exceeds the size of the table is
because this modulo operator gives us
the remainder
of dividing this value by this value and
our remainder can never be larger than
the number that we're dividing by
because if our remainder is equal to or
greater than the number that we're
dividing by that means that we can
divide the number again
for example if we have a hash value that
is 63 and we divide it by a table size
of 10
10 can go into 63 six times and we'll be
left with three
and if we did the same thing for 69
10 would go into 69 six times and we'd
be left with nine
but once we get to 70 and we divided by
10
10 now goes into 70 seven times and
we're left with nothing
so as you can see the remainder is never
larger than
the number that we're dividing by so
coming back to the initialization of our
hash table
if we were to create an instance of hash
table we would pass in
the size of the table that we want as
the table size
and then our hash table would be created
by multiplying a list that contains
one element none by the table size and
this here
is just going to produce something that
looks like this
it's going to be a list that contains
five none values
and then when we create our hash value
this portion of the code
makes sure that our hash value never
exceeds
the table size which ensures that our
hash value
never equals an index that doesn't exist
within our table
and also for those that don't understand
what this ord function is doing
we can use this table here to give you a
general understanding of what's
happening
so in general terms this table gives us
the decimal value
for each character so for example the
character a
here its decimal value is 65
so the character a is always going to be
65. so
if our i is the character a in uppercase
a
because as you can see a lowercase a has
a different value of 97. but if our
character i
is in uppercase a then this order is
going to return
the integer 65 so here 65 is going to be
added to our hash value so in this case
if our key is apple
here we're going to iterate through
every character
in the key apple and we're going to add
to this hash value
starting with 97 and then 112
and then 112 again and so on and so
forth
and that's basically what's happening
when we're using this ord function here
so what's happening when we're adding a
key value to our hash table
so it'll be easier to visualize this if
we change the way that we write this
list out so let's say that we create a
hash table
with a table size of four and we'll
write our list out from top to bottom
so we'll have none none
none
and none and let's just move this
so this is our list and the indexes for
our list are
0 1 2 and 3.
so first of all let's assign a variable
to this hash table instantiation
and we can just call it ht equals hash
table
and if we were to do add key value we
would do
ht dot add
key value
and we would pass in our key and we'll
just say our key
is hi and then we would pass in our
value
and we can just say our value is there
so what's going to happen is we're going
to create a custom hash
out of the key high so our hash value
will start off as zero
and for every character in the string
high
we're going to use this ord function on
the first
character in the string high which is h
and as we can see here
h maps to the decimal 104
and i maps to 105. so what that means is
this ord is going to
return 104 for h and 104 is going to be
added to our hash value which
is zero so our hash value is then going
to be 104
and then we're going to set our hash
value equal to our hash value multiplied
by
what ord returns for h which is 104.
so it's going to be 104 multiplied by
104
which is going to be 10 1816
and then we're going to use the module
operator and we're going to get
the remainder of dividing 10816
by the table size in our table size is
four
so 10 816 divided by four
it's just going to come out to 2704 and
there will be no remainder
so that means this code here is going to
become
zero so our hash value is going to
become zero once again
because since when we divide this number
by our table size
there's no remainder the result of this
expression will be zero
so our hash value is zero again and then
we go to the next character within our
key which is i
and we can erase this and we know that
ord
for the letter i is going to return 105
so we're going to add 105 to 0 and
that's going to be our new hash value
and then our hash value is going to be
set equal to our current hash value
multiplied by 105 because or it's going
to return 105 for the character i
remember so we're going to end up with
105
multiplied by 105 which is going to come
out to
11025 which we will divide by
our table size which is going to come
out to
2 2756.25
so our remainder here is going to be one
so that means our hash value is going to
be one
after this for loop finishes so we're
going to return
one as our hash value so this key value
pair
is going to be added to index 1 because
now
our hash key this custom hash is
returning 1
as our hash key so our hash key is 1
and if our hashed key index of our hash
table
is none which it is it's currently none
we're just going to
set that index of our hash table equal
to a new node containing this data
which will look like this we can remove
this none
and remember we're at index one because
this list here
is our hash table and our index is one
so we're at index one
and we're going to create a new node
which of course
is going to be our rectangle
in our pointer to the next node
and our next node is none because this
is going to be the first node
that we add to this index so our data is
going to contain a key and a value
so our data will be high there
our key and our value for our data
and our next node is going to be none
because this is the first node that
we're adding to this index and the
reason we're using a node here
which is essentially the head of a
linked list is because there's still a
chance that
two different keys result in the same
hash which we would call a collision
so say for example we have this high key
which hashes to index one and we have
another key that hashes to the same
index one
so if that collision happens what we're
going to do is
we're going to go to this else here so
this if
is if the index is none then we can just
add the node right because there's
nothing there
but if there's something there that's
when we get to this else
and if there's something there we're
going to have to traverse the linked
list
until the next node is none and we're
going to have to add that node to where
none is
and point that node to none and in this
particular case
when we do have to traverse the linked
list
within our hash table our insertion is
no longer constant
so the idea here is to reduce the
possibility of having collisions
so that most of the time when we do an
insertion
it's at an index that contains none but
with our hash function
in particular there's a pretty high
probability that we will have collisions
so this isn't a very performant hash
table implementation
but for our purposes to learn how hash
tables actually work
and how they're implemented it doesn't
actually matter as long as you
understand
the concept then i think that we're fine
so next we'll move on to coding what
happens
in this else block okay so now it's time
to move on to
what we'll do if the index specified by
our hashed key
is not none so if it's not none that
means that there's already a node in
that location
so therefore we have a collision and
we're going to need to
use a length list at that particular
index to store
additional values so to do that we're
going to start with the head of the
linked list
which is the first node at the specified
index so we're going to just set node
equal to
self.hash table and then our hashed key
so this is essentially acting as the
head of our linked list
and then we'll traverse the linked list
by using while loop as usual
so while node.nextnode
so as long as there's a next node for
our current node we're going to set node
equal to node.nextnode
and we'll just keep doing this until we
get to the last
node of the linked list so this while
loop will stop
when the next node is none and that
means that our current node is the last
node of the linked list so we don't need
to do anything else to
traverse to the end of this linked list
so once the while loop is complete
we can then set node.nextnode which in
this case when the while loop is
complete the next node to our current
node will be none
so we'll set that empty space to a new
node which will contain our data
and its next node will become none so
now that we're able to add a key value
pair to our hash table
we want to define a method to get the
value for a specified key
and we can just call this one git value
it'll take in self
and the key and again we're going to
need to get our hash
key by using our custom hash method
and passing in our key and i'm not sure
if i clarified this before but
this custom hash method it will always
return the same hash for a given key
and that's very important for our
implementation to work
the same key should always produce the
same hash if there's a chance that the
hash
produced from the same key could be
different then
this wouldn't work at all because in
instances where we need to
actually retrieve the value that we
stored in the hash table
we'd need a way to convert the actual
key back into the hash
to be able to locate the data that we
stored in the first place
and then we're going to check to see if
that key exists within our hash table
so we can do self dot
hash table
hashed key is not none
then we can set our node equal to self
dot
hash table hash key
and then we want to see if this
particular node has data in its next
node because if it does that means that
there's more than one
node stored at this particular index of
our hash table and if that's the case
we need to check to see which one is the
actual key that we're searching for
so if node.nextnode
is none then that means that there's
only one node stored at this index
so we can just return the data for the
current node
but if that's not the case then we're
going to have to traverse the linked
list at the index
so if the key passed to the method is
equal to the key within our data
we'll return the value for that key
but if not we will continue to traverse
our linked list
and since this while loop will only
iterate as long as note dot next node is
not equal to none
for the final node we will need to check
to see if key is equal to
node.data.key and if it is we'll return
node.data.value but if it's not that
means that
the key passed to our method doesn't
exist within our hash table
so at that point we can return and just
so we can see that everything is working
as expected
we can create our own print table method
let's just try to make this look
intuitive
and let's go ahead and see what this
looks like
so we'll create an instance of our hash
table
and we'll pass it 4 for the table size
and then we'll do ht
dot add key value and
let's just do hi there
then let's do ht print table
and let's save and see what happens
and as expected we have a table size of
4 and
at index 1 we have our key and our value
let's go back in here and add
a couple more values so actually
let's just leave them like that
and as you can see since the key high
always hashes to index one
if we add multiple sets of data with the
key high to
our hash table it will all get stored in
a linked list
at the same index
so we can go back in here and try with a
different key
and save and run we see that the key dog
gets hashed to index zero so yeah that
is a general
overview of how to implement a hash
table in python
again you should keep in mind that this
implementation isn't very efficient but
the point is to gain a general
understanding of how hash tables work
and how they're implemented
so for starters we're going to need to
import our hash table module by going
back to the top of our file
and doing the same thing that we did for
our linked list but instead we're going
to use the name of the hash table file
so once we've imported our hash table
module we can head down to
our create blog post route and start
adding the code for this create blog
post
function so we can remove this path and
once again we're going to need to get
the data from the request by using this
request.getjson method
and after we retrieve that data the
first thing that we're going to want to
do is we're going to want to make sure
our user
is it actually a valid user that exists
within our database
because if you remember if we go back up
to our user model
we can see that our user id column
requires that user id
come from our user table and if this is
not the case we'll get a foreign key
constraint error so in order to check if
our user exists we're just going to
query the database for the user that's
passed
in the request so we can just set id
equal to user id and if you remember our
user id
is passed to our create blog post
function via our url
rule so we want to query the first user
with this user id
so we're going to need to add here first
and then we just need to do if not
user and then we'll just return jsonify
message user does not exist
we'll also want to return 400 and a 400
response just means that the client's
into bad requests
so in that case the client would need to
send another request with a user that
actually exists
and once we've made sure our user exists
within our database
we can now start to create a blog post
for that particular user
so we'll start by creating our hash
table and it's just going to be an
instance of hash table from our hash
table module
and we'll just use the size of tin and
we can start adding the values to our
hash table
by using our add key value method that
we created in the last video
so we're going to want to add all of the
parameters to create
a blog post so we're going to need a
title and we're going to get that from
the request
data we'll do the same thing for our
body our date
and our user id
and the date actually won't come from
the requests we're going to
get the date by using this now variable
and if you're unsure of where this comes
from
if you remember from i think the first
video we created this
now variable which is just date time dot
now
and this date time comes from this
import here
where we imported from date time import
date time
and our user id is going to be from the
user id in our url
so now that we've created our hash table
containing our data
let's go ahead and print this hash table
to see what it looks like using
our print table method that we created
in the last video and we can go ahead
and save this
and start up our server
and now that we've started up our server
we need to go to
postman and create a request to create a
blog post
so once you have flask opened up you can
go back to our flask folder
and you can open it and you'll see all
of our previous requests
and we want to create a new post request
for creating a blog post
so we'll just duplicate this one
and we'll just rename it create blog
post
and our rule is going to be blog post
and our user id that we want to create
the blog post for
so we'll just do user id one and then we
need to go to
our body and since we duplicated
the create user post request we still
have this
json data here for our request body so
we can just change the keys and values
within this request payload
and all we need for this payload is the
title of the blog post
and we can just call this post one
and then we need the body of the blog
post
and we can just change this to this is a
blog post or something like that and we
can remove these two
and we also want to remove that and then
we can try to send this
and we get user does not exist and i
think that's actually because
in one of the previous videos we deleted
user id 1.
so let's check our database to make sure
so once again you want to open the db
browser for sqlite
and then open database and then navigate
to our
project folder and then once you're in
our project folder
you can open this sqlite db file and
let's
browse our user table and yes we don't
have user one
it starts at user two so let's just use
user two
and also let's have a look at our blog
post table as well
and if we go all the way to the bottom
here
and we'll see that our latest blog post
is this blog post here
so when we add a new blog post there
should be another blog post following
this one with
id 201 so let's change this to user 2
user id 2 and then send the request
again
and we get an error here but it's
expected because we haven't yet finished
the code for the route we just wanted to
print our hash table to see what it
looks like
so we sent a request to the route to
execute the function
so if we go here you see that we have
our error and it says that the view
function did not return a valid response
and that just means that the function
for our route
is supposed to return a response but we
didn't return anything yet so that's why
we're getting this error
but also before the error we were still
able to print out
our hash table and as you can see
we have a body a date and a title
and actually we have title twice so
there's something
wrong here so let's go back into our
server.pi file
and see what's happening
so here the key for user id is still
title
so that's my bad
change this to user id then save
then run our server again and send the
request again
and now we can go back up to our hash
table and we see that we have
user id at index 0 and it's 2.
then we have our body and our date are
being hashed to the same index
so we have a linked list here containing
two nodes
and then last but not least our title
got hash to
index three so as you can see with our
hash function for our hash table there's
a high probability that
keys will be hashed to the same index so
this is why
this hash table in particular isn't very
performant because the hash function
isn't very efficient but it's actually
good that we're getting the opportunity
to work with an inefficient hash table
implementation because it really helps
you to understand
the most important things that need to
be taken into consideration
when creating your hash table
implementation because whenever we have
keys that get hashed to the same index
in this list
that means that whenever we need to
access a key that's in a linked list at
any given index
we're going to have to traverse in nodes
within being the number of keys added to
that particular index
so when we retrieve data that's
contained within these linked lists
it's still oven as opposed to when we
retrieve data for these indexes that
only contain
one node which takes constant time so as
you can see
the more we can avoid this the more
performant our hash table will be
so ideally we want a hash function and a
table size
that makes instances like this very rare
but i really hope this is helping you
guys to understand
the core concepts of what's happening
behind the scenes with hash tables so
let's go back into
our server.pi file and finish our
function
so we no longer need to print our table
and actually let's go ahead and test
this out with
printing the individual keys within our
hash tables so we can do
ht.getvalue and we can pass in the key
that we want to get the value for
and we can do this for all of our keys
so we'll do body date
user id let's go ahead and save this
and run our server again and then we can
just send this request again
we're going to get an error and as you
can see it printed out our title
post one it printed out our body which
is this is a blog post it printed out
our date time
and it printed out our user id so now
that we know that that's working as
expected we can go ahead and go back
into our server.pi
file and we no longer need this and now
we can just
move forward with creating our blog post
now creating a blog post
is actually pretty straightforward we
can just create a variable called new
blog post
and we have to instantiate a blog post
and again we're using our get value
method to
actually return the values
and then we could just do db.session.add
and then the new blog post instance that
we just created and then we can just
commit the session
and sorry this should be session and
then once that is done we can return
jsonify
we'll do message
new blog post created
and this is going to be a success
response so we'll
return 200 and let's save this and see
if it works
python server.buy servers running and
let's
send this request and we get a success
response new blog post created
and now let's check our database to see
if our blog post is actually stored
within the database
so in the blog post table we can refresh
and we can go back to the bottom of the
table
and you'll see here that we have a new
blog post with id 201
with our title post one and our body
this is blog post
and our date and our user id
now to start in our project directory we
want to create a file
called binarysearchtree.pi
and within that file similar to our
linked lists
and hashtable implementations we want to
create a node class
and the initialization parameters for
this class are going to just be
self and data
and we'll set self.data equal to data
and within a tree structure
instead of the node only pointing to a
next node
it's actually going to point to a left
and a right node
and don't worry if you're having a hard
time visualizing this we'll take some
time to go over what this looks like in
just a second
but for now just know that an individual
node will point to both a left node and
a right node
and we're also going to want to create a
wrapper class for our binary search tree
and this class will just be initialize
with self
and our tree structure will need a root
node which is
the top node of the tree so our root
node will have no parent nodes
and again we're going to go over what
this would look like in a visualization
soon
and next and most importantly we're
going to want to define our methods for
our insertion and for our insertion
methods we're going to need to write
some recursive code
so if you're relatively unfamiliar with
the way that recursion works
i have some videos that can help you to
visualize recursion which can be
accessed by clicking the link currently
displayed on your screen
so to start we can just define our
insert method
which is going to take in self and the
value that we want to
insert and the first thing we'll want to
do is check if
our route is none
and if this is the case this just means
that our top node or the first node
within our tree structure is none which
means our tree
is empty and if that's the case we'll
just set our root
equal to a new node containing our value
and if we go back to our node we see
that when we create a new node and we
pass in the data
the left node and the right node are
both set to none
so when we add this first node to our
tree structure
it's only going to contain a root node
and the root node's going to point to
none for both its left node and its
right node so it will be
a tree structure that only contains one
node so far
and that's if we're inserting a value
into an empty tree structure
else if our tree is not empty we will
need to
use a recursive function to insert into
our tree and this is because we'll
essentially need to find an empty node
to insert our value into
so we haven't yet created this method
but let's just write it out we'll just
call it
insert recursive and the reason
we're starting this method with an
underscore is because this method should
only be used by our
insert method so basically this insert
recursive method
is a private method that belongs to
our insert method
we're going to pass in the value and the
current root
so now we can go ahead and write the
code for this method
and the way that a binary search tree
works is the node's left subtree
so that is the tree that expands from
the node's left node
should only contain values that are less
than the node's value
and the tree's right subtree which is
the tree that expands from the node's
right node
should only contain values greater than
the node's value
which results in the nodes left and
right
subtrees also being binary search trees
and i know that this is quite difficult
to understand with just me describing
the way that a binary search tree should
look but just bear with me we're going
to
go into more details soon but with that
in mind
if the value passed to our insert
recursive method
is less than the past nodes data we're
going to
insert that value in the past node's
left subtree
so if value is less than node.data
we're going to insert value into node's
left subtree and if node.left is none
then that means we can just insert the
value into node.left
so if node.left is none
and node.left will just equal a new node
containing our value else if node.left
is not none
then that means that node.left contains
a node with a value
and that node can also have a left
and a right node so we're going to need
to call our recursive function again
because we would want to do the same
exact thing for the left node we would
want to
make sure our insertion goes into
the left subtree of the left node if
it's less than the left node or the
right subtree
of the left node if it's greater than
the left node so we'll just do
self.insert recursive
and again we'll pass in the value and
this time we would pass in node.left
and that's what we would do if value is
less than node.data but if value is
greater than node.data
we would do the same thing but this time
we would do it on
node.write so we can do l if value is
greater
than node.data we'll check if node.write
is none
and if it is we'll just set node.right
equal to
a new node containing our value
else once again we would call our
insert recursive function passing in our
value and node.right
and last but not least else we would
just
return and this is because if the value
isn't less than node.data and the value
isn't
greater than node.data then that means
the value is equal to
node.data so our else would be if the
value is equal to node.data
and if the value is equal to node.data
that means that the value is already
contained within our tree
and a binary search tree shouldn't have
duplicates so if that is the case we're
going to do nothing here
so now let's take some time to try and
visualize what's happening here
okay so let's start by visualizing what
would happen if we create an instance of
our node class
so we can imagine that we create a
variable
node and that variable is going to be
an instance of a node and we'll pass
in some random data so let's just say
the number 15.
and this instantiation is going to look
something like
this we'll have a node here and it will
contain
15 and then we'll have a left and a
right
left right and these will also be nodes
which will contain none
so as you can see here self.left is
going to be none
and self.write is going to be none as
well and then our data
our actual node is going to be 15. so
this is how we can visualize an instance
of a node
so let's go ahead and erase this and see
what it would look like
if we create an instance of an actual
binary search tree
so let's say we call our binary search
tree bst
and we set it equal to an instance of
binary search tree
this is going to give us an empty binary
search tree with the
root set equal to none and the root is
just
the first node within the tree so a tree
might look something like this
this here is our root node
and in our binary search tree if this
root node is empty
then that means that the entire tree is
empty
let's just draw this again so now that
we've created an
instance of binary search tree we have
an empty
binary search tree here now let's say we
want to call our
insert method
and pass in the value 20. we're going to
end up here at insert and the value is
going to be 20.
and if self.root is none which it is
it's empty
then self.root's going to become a new
node with that value
20. so this is going to become 20 and
this new nodes left
and right are both none so the left is
pointing to none
and the right is pointing to 9 as well
and for none we just won't put
anything into the node and here's our
root
left right
now let's say we insert another value
and this time we'll insert one so what's
going to happen is we're going to end up
here again
and this time our root is not none so
we're going to move on to this recursive
insert so we'll end up here with our
value
being 1 and we're going to pass in the
root so
our node here is going to be our root
which is 20. and we're
going to check if our value 1
is less than our node which is our root
20. and if it is it means that it needs
to go into
our node's left node because as
explained before
in a binary search tree a node's left
node has to be less than the node
and the node's right node has to be
greater than the node
so if value is less than node.data
so if 1 is less than 20 and if
node.leftnode is none
which it is then we're just going to
insert that one
into the left node and then we'll
continue with another
insert
and this time we'll insert two and we're
going to end up here
and root is not none so we're going to
call the recursive function again
passing in the root and our value 2 and
this time we'll end up here
with our node being root and our value
being 2
and our value is less than our root
which is 20. so 2 is less than 20
but this time our left node of our root
is not none
it's one so now we need to call the
recursive function again
this time passing in our two and our
left node which is one
so we end up back up here with our value
being
2 and our node being our left node now
which is 1. so now 2 is not less than
1. 2 is actually greater than 1.
so that's going to bring us here 2
is greater than 1 our left node is 1.
and this node's right node is none
so we'll just add our 2 there
so here we're just going to add our 2.
and let's do another
vst insert
and let's do 30. so now we'll end up
here
our roots not none so once again we pass
to the recursive
function our value being 30
and then our root so we'll end up here
again
now our value is 30 and our node is our
root node which is 20
and 30 is not less than 20. 30 is
greater than 20.
so we'll end up here and our right node
of our root node is none right now so we
can just
add this 30 here
and this would just go on and on and our
root nodes
write node will always contain a value
that's greater than our root node and
our root node's
left node will always contain a value
that's less than
our root node and the same thing for
these
child nodes this left node's right node
will always contain a value that's
greater than our left node
and this left node's left node will
always contain a value
that's less than our left node
and it would just keep going that way
so for example the value here would have
to be less than 1
and the same for here the value here
would have to be less than 30 and the
value here would have to be greater than
30.
and you're going to see why this is
necessary when we're actually
implementing
our binary search method now really
quickly i want to go over something that
is important for you all to understand
that is that the order in which we make
insertions into the binary search tree
matters and it will impact the
performance of our tree
currently if we were to try to search
this tree for the node containing the
value
30 we'd be able to leverage our root
node as a midpoint
and we'd be able to completely avoid
traversing
any node to the left of our root because
we know that any node to the left of our
root
or within this left subtree will be less
than
the value 20 our root value which will
therefore
be less than the value 30 which would
leave us with the right subtree to
traverse
to find the value 30 without ever
needing to traverse the left subtree
now if this is confusing to you i
suggest you watch my video on how binary
search works which you can
access by clicking the link currently
displayed on your screen
but continuing with my point the reason
that the order in which we make
insertions into the binary search tree
matters is because the order of
insertion impacts the structure of the
tree
so currently with the order in which
we've made our insertions
we have a balanced binary search tree
because the height of our roots left
subtree
which is 2 1 2 differs from
the height of our roots right sub tree
which is 1
only by 1. so that is the height of our
left subtree
is 2 and the height of our right subtree
is 1
and 2 minus 1 is 1 so
the difference between our two subtrees
is only one which makes this binary
search tree balanced
and it's not within the scope of this
series
but it is something that you will need
to become familiar with as you go deeper
into working with binary search trees
but continuing with my point the reason
that the order in which we make
insertions into the binary search tree
matters is because the order of
insertion impacts the structure of the
tree so with this
insertion order that we currently have
we are left with
a balanced binary search tree but if we
were to change the order of insertion
we could be left with a completely
different tree structure to demonstrate
that
let's insert these same values into our
tree but this time in order from
smallest to largest
so we can start by just erasing this
current tree structure
and we'll leave this here for your
reference but this is no longer
the insertion that we're using to create
our tree so let's create our new
insertion
here so we'll do bst
dot insert
and this time we'll start with one and
what's going to happen is
our tree is null so one is going to
become our root
so we'll just have one as our root node
and then we'll do
bst dot insert
and this time we'll insert 2 and we'll
end up here
and then we'll go down to our recursive
and we'll pass
in the value 2 and our root which is 1
and then we'll end up here
our value two is greater than our root
which is one
and our roots right node is none so we
would just add to our roots right node
the value two
then we insert again
and this time we'd insert 20 and again
we'd end up
here insert recursive value 20
root 1 and our value 20 is greater than
our root but our right node
already contains a value so we would
insert again this time passing our right
node
and our value 20 and we'd end up back at
the top here
and now our right node is the node and
our
value is 20 and our value 20 is greater
than our right node
which is only two and this node's right
value
is none so we would just insert that 20
here
so we'd end up like this and then
last but not least we'd insert
our 30 and we do the same thing we'd end
up here
eventually leading us to adding our 30
here
now as you can see this tree structure
here is very similar to a linked list
that is to find 30 we would need to
traverse through
every node so we would have to go to
this node's right node this node's right
node this node's right node
and finally arrive at 30 which would
make searching this structure
in particular take linear or o of n time
so with this example you can see how
insertion order can have a substantial
impact on the performance of our binary
search tree now we won't be getting into
it in this tutorial
but this is something that we can manage
by coding our binary search tree in such
a way that it is self-balancing
which would therefore make it an avl
tree or a self-balancing binary search
tree but this is out of the scope of
this series
for now it's only important that you
understand that the tree structure will
differ depending on the order in which
we make insertions and that in turn will
affect the performance of our tree so
let's move forward with adding the rest
of the methods to our binary search tree
class
okay so before we add our search methods
into our binary search tree class
let's go back into our server file
and set up our route and actually this
rule
should be blog post
and then blog post id
so this route is going to be used to
retrieve one blog post based on its id
and we'll change this also to blog post
id
and we'll go ahead and remove this pass
and the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to
query all of our blog posts by doing
blog post dot
and what this is going to do is it's
going to return to us
a list of blog posts in ascending order
and we're going to
insert those blog posts into our binary
search tree
and we're going to use the search method
on our binary search tree to search for
and retrieve a specific blog post and
our binary search tree search and insert
methods are going to be
based on our blog posts id so if you
remember
nodes within our binary search tree have
to be inserted in a particular way
such that a node's left node can't be
larger than the node
and the node's right node must be larger
than the node and the value that we're
going to use to determine this
is our blog post id and if you remember
if we
insert into our binary tree in ascending
order we're essentially going to get a
tree structure similar to a list
and there are actually only a couple of
ways for that particular
linear tree structure to be produced and
that is if we insert nodes in ascending
order and if we insert them
in descending order because as shown in
our example
when you insert nodes in order from
smallest to greatest
we're just going to keep adding nodes to
the previous node's write node which
will result in a list like structure and
the same thing would happen if we
insert nodes from largest to smallest
but in that case
the list like structure would be in the
other direction
but it would still be a list like
structure so our way to solve this
is we're going to attempt to create a
more balanced tree structure by
randomizing our inserts
so basically we're going to take this
ascending order by id
blog post list and we're just going to
shuffle it using this random module
and we need to import that random module
so let's go here
and do import random
so now our blog post list will no longer
be in ascending order it'll be in a
completely random order
and when we iterate through it and add
it to our binary search tree
our tree structure will also be
randomized
and with this random tree structure we
have a better chance of getting a
balanced binary search tree which in
turn will increase the overall
performance of our tree
so now we also need to import our binary
search tree module so we can go back up
here
and similar to our hash table we can
just do binary search tree
and we can create a binary search tree
instance
and we can insert into our tree by doing
for post
in blog posts bst.insert
and we're actually going to insert
dictionaries as our individual blog
posts
so we're actually going to need to go
back into our
binary search tree insert method and
make some changes
so we will do id and that's going to be
post.id
and we need title body and user so let's
change this to title
and same here
and once we've generated our binary
search tree we can create a post by
just doing vst.search which we have not
yet
implemented but we will and search is
going to return
the blog post of the past blog post id
and the idea is for our binary search
tree to be a balanced tree so that our
search takes logarithmic time and lastly
we're going to do if not post
because our search method is going to
return false
if the blog post for the corresponding
id is not found
and if that's the case we're going to
return jsonify
post not found
and if the post is found we'll just
return jsonify
post
so let's go ahead and save this and go
back into our binarysearchtree.5 file
and here we're going to need to make
changes to our
insert recursive so we're going to be
changing this value
to data because we're no longer
inserting just a single value we're
inserting a dictionary
and when we do these comparisons we're
going to
be comparing the ids within the
dictionary so this would be changed to
data
id and this would be id as well
so now we're comparing the past data's
id
to the nodes data's id
here data same for here
and also for this insert method we're
going to do the same thing
data data
data so let's go ahead and see if this
works
so we'll save here we'll run our server
and then we'll go and add another
request to postman to get a single blog
post based on its id so once you have
postman open once again we can go to
our flask api folder and hit add request
and we'll just call it get blog post
and save to flask api
and we'll go to get blog post then our
url
and this is just going to be blog post
and an
id so let's just do five and let's go
ahead and send this request
and we get an error binary search tree
has no attribute search
because we haven't yet implemented our
search method so let's go ahead and do
that before we move forward
so binary search tree
so our search method is going to be
fairly similar to our insert method in
that it's going to be
a recursive method
so we'll define search
and we'll take self and blog post
id and let's change this
and the blog post id that we get from
the url is going to be a string
so we're going to want to convert it
into int
because when we're comparing it to the
blog post
id within our data it's going to be
compared to and
we'll do blog post id as an int is our
new blog post id
and then self dot root is none
we're just going to return false because
if that's the case it means our binary
search tree is empty
so of course a blog post cannot exist
within it
but otherwise we're going to return
self.underscore search
recursive similar to the way we did our
insert this search recursive method is
going to be
a private method that belongs to our
search method
and we're going to pass in the blog post
id and self.root
so now let's add this search recursive
method
it's going to take blog post id and node
and since this is a recursive function
we need a base case and our base case is
going to be
if the node passed in left node and
right node is none then we're going to
return
false
and first we'll check if our blog post
id is equal to
the current node's data's id and if
that's the case then we'll just return
the current node because that means that
we found our node
so if blog post id is equal to node.data
id and just return
node.data but if we're not so lucky
we'll need to traverse the tree so
if blog post id is less than node.data
then we'll check to see if the blog post
id is equal to
our node's left node's data id so if
blog post id is equal to node.left.data
id if that's the case we can just return
node.left.data
but if it's not the case we're going to
return
self dot search cursive
our blog post id and this time our left
node
so again this is similar to our insert
and we're going to do the same thing if
blog post id
is greater than node.data
id and if blog post id is greater than
our node data's id then that means we're
going to search the write subtree
so if blog post id is equal to
node.write.data id
and we'll just return node.right.data
but if not we'll recurse down our
write subtree by passing in the blog
id and node.write node
so let's take a couple of seconds to go
over what's happening here
so if we can't find our blog post id
within our binary search tree
we will reach this base case which will
just return false
meaning that we couldn't find it and if
our root node is in fact the data that
we're searching for
then we'll just return that root node
but if our blog post id
is less than our root note then we're
going to traverse
the left subtree because the right
subtree will only contain
values that are greater than our blog
post id
and then we check to see if the top node
of our left sub
tree is the data that we're searching
for and if it is we'll just return that
node
but if not we're going to recurse down
that left subtree
and the same goes for if our blog post
id is greater than our root node's data
if that's the case then we're going to
traverse our right subtree
because the left subtree will only
contain values that are less than
our midpoint which is our root node so
if the top node
of our right subtree is the data that
we're searching for
then we can just return that but if not
we'll need to recurse down
our write subtree and that's going to be
our search method so let's go ahead and
save this
and let's try running our server again
and in postman
let's try sending our requests to get
blog post with id5 once again
and we get post not found so let's check
our database and see if we have a blog
post with the id5
so again you want to open your db
browser and go to open database
and then open your db file and let's go
to blog post browse table
and we do in fact have a blog post with
the id5 so there's something wrong with
our code
so let's go back into our server.fi
file and let's see what's happening here
okay let's go into our search method and
have a look
ah i see so unreachable code because
this returned we didn't
add the proper indentation so this
should be here
and now let's go ahead and save and
let's run our server again
and back in postman let's go ahead and
send the request for blog post with id5
again
and we get our blog post and we get our
body
our id our title and our user id
let's try it with another blog post
let's do 199
and we get a blog post for id 199
and now let's try it for a blog post
that we know
does not exist so we can just put in
some random numbers here
and we get another error so let's see
what's happening
let's close our server and let's go into
binarysearchtree.pie
sorry about that so this was a pretty
big oversight on my part
so we're going to remove this here
and we're going to add to this portion
and node.left
is not none
and we'll do the same thing here but
we'll do
if node.right is not none
and then we need to return false here
so what was happening was we were trying
to compare the blog post id
to node.data of a left node
or a write node which was actually equal
to none
so there was no way to access the data
of none so now let's save this
and run our server again and in postman
we can try to
send a request to retrieve this blog
post with this
random id that we know doesn't exist
once again
and this time we'll get post not found
and if we put an id that does exist
let's say 200
we'll get the blog post and let's take
this a step further
and just put a really random long number
and send it and we get post not found
and
now we've created our route to retrieve
a blog post for a particular blog id
and we've made use of our binary search
tree to search for
and retrieve that particular blog post
and just really quick let's go into our
server.pi file
and here where we did our last route
which made use of our binary search tree
the definition of this function get all
blog posts
is actually wrong so let's go ahead and
change this to
get one blog post
and we can save this and now we're going
to create
a new file for our queue implementation
and we'll call it custom queue.pi
and to start off our queue we're going
to create a class for
a node and this is going to be the same
node class that we use for a linked list
and actually our queue is basically just
going to be
a linked list where inserts and removals
are done in a first
in first out order and we'll go deeper
into what that means in just a second so
let's just
go ahead and define our node
so if you've been watching up to this
point you should be familiar with this
node class
next we'll add a class for our cue
and for our cue class we want to keep
track of the head
and the tail
and the head is just going to be the
head of our linked list
of course and the tail is going to be
the last
node of our linked list and to
insert data into the queue we're going
to define
enqueue
sorry and enqueue will only ever add
nodes
to the end or the tail of our linked
list
so you can just think of it as a line of
customers at starbucks or something
like if you get in line like new
customers can't just go to the front of
the line
just like a new node can't just be added
to the head of this linked list
a new customer would have to go to the
end of the line which is what this
enqueue method is going to do it's going
to add a new node to the end of our
linked list
and to do that first if our queue is
empty both
self.tail and self.head are going to be
none
so if self.tail is none
and self.head is none and if that's the
case the node that we're inserting is
going to be both
our tail and our head because there will
only be
one node in our list so it'll be
self.tail
equals self.head which equals a new node
containing our data and it's going to
point to none
and then we'll just return so this is
what we'll do if our queue is empty
but if the queue isn't empty we want to
add our new node
to the last node's next node so
self.tail.nextnode
is going to be equal to a new node which
will contain our data
and it will point to none because this
will be our new tail
so it will be set to our new tail so
self.tail
is going to equal self.tail.nextnode
which is the one that we just created
here and then we'll just return
now that's how we're going to add to our
queue
now we need to remove from our queue as
well so we need to create the method to
remove from our queue so this is going
to be called dq
so define dq
self and dq is only going to remove from
the head of our linked list
so keeping with the starbucks example
the front of the line the person that's
at the register
making their order that's going to be
the first person removed from the line
and it's going to be the same with this
queue notes can only be removed from the
queue
from the head of the linked list or
front of the line so that means
if self.head is none
then that means that our queue is empty
so we'll just return none and if our
queue is not empty
when we dequeue we're going to want to
return the node so we'll just store it
in this removed
variable so our self.head our current
head is going to be
set to our remove variable and then
we'll set our new head
self.head is equal to our current head
self.head dot next node
and that's how we're removing from the
queue we don't need to worry about
allocating memory or anything like that
because
python has garbage collection so all we
need to do is
change what node our head is pointing to
and next itself.head is none
which means that if when we
change where our head is pointing to it
ends up pointing to
a next node that is none that means that
the head of our
q was also the tail of our q which means
that if we dequeue that last node then
our length list or
our q is now empty because the only node
in this linked list that will have a
next node pointing to none is going to
be the tail right
so if after completing this our head is
none then that means that
our linked list is now empty so we need
to update our tail
as well to point to none so we'll just
do self.dale
equals none and then lastly we want to
return
the node that we removed from the queue
so we'll return
removed and it's as simple as that a
queue is just a linked list where we
control
insertions and removals in such a way
that inserting and removing from the
linked lists
happens in first in first out order so
let's take a couple of minutes to try
and visualize what's happening here
okay so let's take some time to try and
visualize our cue
so let's do a quick refresher on how we
visualize our node
we're going to visualize our node like
this
our data and our pointer to next node
and of course this node can point to
another node which can point to another
node
essentially creating a linked list and
that's one thing that you should
understand about a queue a queue is
essentially just a linked list
it's a linked list with certain
specifications for how we insert
and how we remove nodes from the linked
list
so let's just go over a quick example of
adding nodes to
our queue and then removing them so
let's erase this
and let's go ahead and create an
instance of a queue which we'll just
call
q and
it's always weird spelling the word q
and then once we have an instance of the
q
we can do q dot
n q
some data and what that's going to look
like is we're going to end up here
and if self.tail is none and self.head
is none
then self.tail equals self.head
equals our node which means that we're
going to
add a node here with our data
it's going to point to none because as
you can see it's a new node
and it's going to point to none and this
node is going to become both
our head
and our tail
and i apologize for this so then we can
come in and do
q dot in q once again
this one will do data two and what's
going to happen is we're going to end up
here again
and we're not going to have to go
through this because we don't have an
empty queue
so we're going to end up here
self.tail.nextnote is going to equal
our new node so in a queue we're always
just going to
add to the back of the queue it's just
like a line at starbucks
you can't just jump to the front of the
line and buy your fancy coffee you have
to wait
in the line full of other starbucks
coffeeers
or whatever so what we're going to do is
we're just going to do
self.tail.nextnode equals a new node
so this is our tail right so the tails
next node is just going to be this new
node with data
2. and it's going to point to none and
let's add another one maybe somebody
else wants to get some coffee
we'll call this one data3 of course and
we'll end up here again and we're just
going to add it to the back of the line
simple right oh and i'm sorry i forgot
so this tail
no longer points to this one because
after we added it to the back of the
line we set self.tail equal to
self.tail.nextnode so
self.tail.next is this node so this
tail is now going to point here
i hope that didn't confuse you because
that was
before doing this okay so now we're back
to
doing this and we'll end up here and
we're going to
do self.tail.nextnote equal to a new
node so our tails
next node is going to be equal to a new
node
and that one's going to be data 3
and it's gonna point to none
this is none again sorry about that all
right so now that we've
created our starbucks line oh sorry once
again i forgot to
change the tail so now our tail
is going to point to here
so this is our last person in line and
this is the person in the middle and
this is the person at the front of the
line the head
okay so now what we want to do is see
how dq works so dq
works like this we're just going to do q
dot
dq
and of course we're not going to pass
anything to dq because we have no
control over what gets removed from dq
because it's always going to remove the
head of our list
so dq we're going to end up here if
self.head is none we're going to return
none of course because that means that
there is no
line there is no queue and we're going
to store our head
in the removed so we can return it and
then our self.head is just going to be
equal to self.head.nextnode
so all we're going to do is we're just
going to
move this from pointing to that head to
pointing here
and we're just going to leave this here
and eventually this will be garbage
collected
so our new head is this and here let's
let's actually let's let's step through
so we can get to this portion so you can
see what's actually happening here
so let's do q dot dq
again really bad at spelling
q and when we dequeue again
we're going to set our head
to this one because once again we do
self.head as equal self.head.nextnode so
it's going to be equal to this one
so now our head and our tail are both
the same node
and let's just pretend our garbage
collector came along
and garbage collected these
so now this is what we're left with our
head and our tail are both the same node
now at this point
if we dq again q dot dq
if we see here our next note is none and
we're going to set our self.head
to our next node which is none so let's
erase this
and let's change it to 0.2
this none so now our head is set to none
but our tail is still pointing to this
node here
even though this guy was actually
removed from the queue
and as long as this tail is pointing to
this node here
this node will never be garbage
collected either so what we need to do
is once our head gets set to none
if self.head is none so if if we moved
our head to be set to none
like we just did self.head is going to
equal none right
our head equals none if that's the case
we need to set our tail to none as well
because this tail pointing to this is no
longer accurate our tail is now none as
well
because there's no longer anything left
in the queue so at this point
we're going to move this to point to
none
and then this guy is going to get
garbage collected
he's going to the trash so now both our
head
and our tail are pointing to none which
means that our q
is empty and that's how we can visualize
how
nodes are added and removed from our
queue
and how we can visualize our queue in
general okay so now that we understand
how we can visualize our queue
let's go back into our server.pi file
and make use of it for one of our
endpoints
and we're going to change this rule
to blog post forward slash
numeric body we're going to change this
to get numeric
post bodies and what this route is
essentially going to do is it's going to
convert our blog post bodies to
a numeric value containing the total of
each individual
character within the body's ascii
decimal equivalent
so it sounds complicated but basically
all it's going to do is it's going to
iterate through each character within
our body
and it's going to add all the characters
within our body up by their decimal
value
so our body is just going to be
converted into one integer
and we're no longer going to need to
access that blog post variable
and we're going to get our blog posts
from our database by doing
blogpost.query.all
then we're going to create a queue which
we'll just call
q and it's going to be from custom q
and instance of q and we have to import
our custom q module
we'll go here
change that to custom cue
and now we want to add every post from
our
blog post to our queue so for post
in blog posts we want to do
q dot enqueue
and pass in our post as the data and
we're going to return a list
so let's create a return list which is
just going to be an empty list for now
so at this point our queue contains all
of the posts from this blog post query
and what we want to do is we want to
dequeue and process
each post until our queue no longer
contains any more posts
so to do that we're just going to loop
through the length
of our blog posts because the length of
our blog posts
is the number of posts that we have in
our queue as well
so we can just use that number for our
loop
to dequeue each item within our queue so
we'll do post
equals q dot dq
and if you remember dq is going to
return
the value that's removed and that's
going to be
passed to our post variable then we want
to create a
variable for numeric body we'll just
start it off as 0
and now we want to loop through every
character in our post body
and convert it into its integer
equivalent from our ascii table
and then we want to add that to our
numeric body
so for char and post data dot
body numeric body plus equals
then ord and then char
and this ord function is just a built-in
function
that will convert our character into its
integer ascii equivalent and now our
post.data.body
is going to be set equal to the numeric
body instead of the actual
blog post body and then
our return list we're going to append
our blog post dictionary containing the
new body
so this body is now going to just be a
numeric value
or an integer
and lastly outside of our for loop we
want to return
jsonify our return list
so let's take a second to go over what
this is doing
so at this line here we're just creating
an empty queue
an instance of our queue and if we go to
our queue
we should remember that we have two
methods on our queue
in queue and dq and we should also
remember that a queue does
insertion and removal in first in first
out order so whenever we enqueue we're
adding to the
end of our linked list or the end of our
queue or the back of the line
if that's easier for you to visualize
and whenever we dequeue
we're removing from the head of our
linked list or the front of our line
so here for each blog post the blog
posts are in ascending order
and we're adding them to our queue in
ascending order as well because we're
iterating through them
in its ending order so for example if we
have blog post id one
two and three when we enqueue the first
one one
it's going to become the first and last
node of our queue
then when we enqueue the second one two
it's going to
get added to the end of our queue so
it's gonna get added after one and then
the same for three it's going to get
added after two
then here when we dequeue it we're
dequeuing it in ascending order first we
dequeue
id1 then we dq id2 and then we dq id3
and so on and so forth so essentially
these posts
are waiting in line to have their
characters converted into integers
so once one node has its body's
characters converted into integers
it gets appended to our return list and
then we go on to the next item in the
queue and eventually we get to a point
where our queue is empty
and at that point we'll just return the
entire list
so let's go ahead and test this out so
let's start our server python server.pi
and back in postman we'll create a new
request
and we'll just call it git numeric body
and we'll save it to flask api open it
up
let's go into this blog post
and take this
and our rule is blog post forward slash
numeric
body and let's go ahead and send this
and see what happens
and as you can see we get our blog post
back
and the bodies are now converted into a
single
integer okay so now to implement our
stack
we can create a file called stack.pi
and again we'll start with creating a
class called node
which will have the same structure as
our linked list node as well
and this is because a stack is also
essentially just a linked list
and just like our queue the only
difference between a normal linked list
and a stack
is a stack does insertions and removals
in last
in first out order so let's go over what
that means
by creating our class for stack
so for our stack we only need to keep
track of the top
and the top is essentially the same as
the head of our linked list
we're just going to call it top because
when we visualize it top is going to
actually make more sense
and you'll see what i mean when we go to
the blackboard explanation
so self dot top equals
none for now and we can just define a
method called peak
to just see what our current top is and
all this is going to do
is return self.top and we'll define
another method
called push and this is how we're going
to
insert nodes onto our stack
and all we're going to do with our push
is we're going to replace our current
head with the new node
and then make our current head the next
node so we're basically just
placing this node on top of our current
head and then
that node becomes our new head so we'll
create a next node variable to store
our current top and i'm sorry if i'm
saying top and head interchangeably
that's because they're the same thing
so don't get confused and then our new
top
is going to be a new node which contains
our data
and next node and our next node is going
to be our current top
or head and then we set our new top
equal to
our new top and this is the only way
that we can add to the stack
we only can add it to the head of our
stack or the top of our stack
or the head of our linked list i hope
this isn't getting too confusing it's
actually very simple
and i'll show you soon and for removing
from our stack it's also very simple
we'll define a method called pop
and all pop is going to do is remove the
head or remove the top and whichever
node is next from the head
is going to become our new top that's it
so if self.top
is none that means that we have an empty
stack so we'll just return none and
again we want to keep track
of the removed node because we want to
return it
and we'll set our new top equal to
self.top.nextnode
very simple then we'll just return
removed
and that's going to be it for our stack
implementation
so let's go ahead and take some time to
see what
this code is actually doing as well and
you'll find that it's very similar to
the queue which is very similar to
our linked lists because they're all
essentially the same thing
okay so let's take some time to try to
visualize
a stack so we're already familiar with
how to visualize a node
but when we visualize it in the context
of a stack
we're going to flip our node so what i
mean by that
is with linked list we visualize our
node this way
with our data being here and then our
pointer to next node being here
and then this would be our head
and then there would be other nodes
right and that would be a linked list
well for a stack we're just going to
look at it this way we're going to
have it like this we'll have our data
here
and we'll have our pointer to the next
node like this
and instead of calling this head we'll
call it the top
of the stack and if we were to have
another item in the stack it would look
like this
as well
okay so let's erase this
and let's go ahead and create an
instance of the stack we'll just call it
st
equals a new stack
instance and let's do
dot push and we'll push
some data and what that's going to look
like is we're going to end up here
and our next node is going to equal
self.top and currently our self.top is
none
so our next node's going to be none and
then our new top
is going to be a new node with our data
and this
new node's next node is going to be this
next node that we created which is none
and then we'll set our self.top equal to
that new top so what will that look like
that's going to look like this
so we're going to add a node
with our data and it's going to be
pointing to
none and then this is going to be
our self dot top
and now let's go here and add another
one push
say data 2 and we're going to end up
here again
and now our next node is going to be our
self.top
so our next node is going to be this
node and our new top is going to be a
new node
with its next node being this next node
which is this one so all we need to do
is we just need to create
a new one data 2
and its next node remember its next node
is going to be the current top
so its next node is just going to be
this node
see our new top is a new node with our
next node being this node
and then self.top is now going to be
equal to our new top which is this one
so this will no longer be our top this
will now be our top and we would do the
same thing
if we added another item we would add it
here
and this new node's next node would be
our current top and then we would change
the top
to this new node and so on and so forth
so what happens when we do pop so pop it
will only ever remove the head
it'll never remove anything below the
head so if self.top is none
we're just going to return none because
if top is none that means that our stack
is empty right but in our case it's not
none
so we're going to store our current top
which is this one
in a removed variable so we're going to
store this
in our remove variable and then our
current top
we're going to set it equal to
self.top.nextnode
so we're going to set it equal to our
top's next
node so all we're doing is we're just
changing this to point to this one
and we're just removing this point here
and then we're just returning the
removed
so we're returning the removed which is
this one so it's getting popped off and
returned and it's this one and this is
going to just sit here we don't need to
do anything with this because it'll be
garbage collected so eventually
something's going to come along and
clean this up
and we're going to be left with just
this top and if we push on to the stack
again we're always going to push on to
the top and when we remove from the
stack
we're always going to remove from the
top
and that is how we can visualize a stack
okay so now that we can visualize our
stack let's go back into
our server.pi file
and first and foremost let's just import
our stack
and for our very last route we're going
to use
our stack to delete the last 10 blog
posts
within our database so we'll
change this to delete last
10 and we can also
change this to delete last in
and again we don't need that blog post
to be passed in
and here once again we're going to do
blog posts
equals blog post dot query dot all
and we'll call our stack instantiation s
and we'll just do stack dot
stack to create a new instance of stack
and
similar to our blog post we're going to
iterate through our blog post
and then we're going to push them onto
our stack
so now what we want to do is we want to
loop through pops of our stack so
we could do four in range
10 and then we're going to do post to
delete equals stop pop
and if you remember pop is going to
return
the node that we're popping off of our
stack
and once we have that node we can
actually delete it by doing db.session
dot delete and putting in our post to
delete
and then this is session not sessions
and then dv.session.commit
and if it's successful we're going to
return jsonify
and we'll just say success
now if you're wondering why this deletes
the last 10 blog posts
it's because if you remember how a stack
works insertions
and removals are done in last in first
out order
so if we go to our push method we'll see
that whenever we push
a node onto our stack it gets pushed to
the top of our stack
or to the head of our linked list
and this blog posts query is a list of
blog posts
in ascending order so if we're pushing
onto our stack blog posts in ascending
order
the blog post with id 1 is going to get
pushed on
first and then every blog post following
blog post with id 1
is going to get put on top of blog post
1
eventually resulting in the top of our
stack
being the last blog post in our database
so if the last blog post in our database
is 200
the top of our stack is going to be blog
post with id 200 and the bottom of our
stack is going to be blog post with id1
so when we loop through 10 times we're
looping through
and we're popping off the stack the top
node for each iteration
we're just popping off 200 then 199
then 198 then 197 and so on and so forth
until we pop off tin and for each one
that we pop off the stack we're going to
delete it from the database
so it results in us removing the last 10
items in the database
every time we run this loop so let's go
ahead and test this out
we can run our server again
and we're going to want to open our
database to see our data to make sure
that the right blog posts are being
removed so we want to open our database
then we can browse table for our blog
post and we can go all the way to the
bottom
and we'll see that our last blog post id
is 201 so if we were to remove
10 blog posts from here if we refresh
this after calling that endpoint we
should only be left with up to id 191
so let's go into postman and create a
new
request so add request
delete last tin
blog post delete last
10 and it's going to be
method delete and let's go ahead and
send this and see what happens
and we got an error so let's go see what
happened
so let's go into our server.pi file
and the issue is i didn't add data
to this post to delete because if we
remember
our pop returns a node and a node
contains data as our data so we need to
access the data
by extending this data attribute so
let's go ahead and save
run our server again and let's go try
this again
so we'll send the request and this time
we get success so now let's go and check
our database and see if the proper blog
posts have been removed
so within our database we can go ahead
and refresh
and go down to the bottom once again and
as you can see we only have blog posts
up until id 191 so it's working as
expected
and that's going to be it for this
tutorial congratulations for making it
to the end
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
subscribe to my youtube channel
and follow me on instagram and twitter
at essie like a pro
i make content like this every week so
if this is something that you're
interested in
be sure to drop on by and of course if
you haven't already
please like this video and subscribe to
free code camp for more exceptional
content
anyways i hope that you all have enjoyed
this video and i hope that you've
learned something
and it's been a pleasure i'll see you in
the next one